[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat si vous nous rejoignez ce matin
nous vous proposons de suivre en direct
l'audition de françois bayrou haut
commissaire au plan
il est auditionné ce matin par les
sénateurs membres de la commission des
affaires économiques
il s'exprimera sur la crise mais aussi
sur le plan de relance je vous propose
d'écouter ces échanges et on se retrouve
après citoyenne qui vous paraîtrait en
décalage avec le diagnostic des experts
votre première publication le 28 octobre
dernier et très synthétique elle brosse
en une douzaine de pages un scénario
intitulé et si l'aco vite du rêve et je
suggère si vous en est d'accord que vous
puissiez bien sûr rapidement évoqué vos
recommandations alors que nous sommes
ici au sénat très inquiets à la fois des
difficultés d'anticipation actuelle du
gouvernement et la situation
d'exaspération des français
permettez moi ce stade posé plusieurs
questions à la fois concrète et
transversal la première concerne notre
endettement et la politique de relance
industrielle d'un côté bien sûr comme
les français nous appelons tous de nos
voeux la relocalisation industrielle et
pour cela le pays va durablement
s'endetter via son plan de relance
bien sûr l'endettement est à la fois
moyens de sauvetage immédiat nous voyons
est un moyen de prospective mais c'est
aussi nous savons tous depuis longtemps
une bombe à retardement
l'état cherche donc à trouver les
sources de désendettement l'une de ses
sources et la cession de ses
participations géré par la paix ou dans
certaines entreprises
pourriez vous nous apportez votre avis
d'expert sur cette politique de cessions
des participations de l'état
certaines participations nous paraissent
stratégique d'un point de vue industriel
je pense aux chantiers de l'atlantique
que l'état souhaite céder pour moins de
100 millions est maintenant un ticket de
100 millions ça nous paraît très faible
je pense aussi à adp qui nous a beaucoup
occupés lors de la loi pacte globalement
le volume total du portefeuille de
l'état représentent moins de 5% de sa
dette
pensez vous que la cession de nos actifs
soit une solution souhaitable dans cette
période la mobilisation de l'épargné
nationale ne vous semblerait t'elle pas
préférable à des transferts potentiels
de savoir faire nous avons également
besoin de votre avis sur le sujet
fondamental
télétravail le télétravail est par
nature délocalisables il se pose un saut
en avant technologique comme l'a
souligné thierry breton d'un point de
vue social aussi bien qu'économique
au regard de la productivité du risque
de désocialisation
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur les
équilibres qu'il conviendrait donc de
construire dans la guerre sanitaire
puisque c'est le terme consacré par le
président de la république l'une de vos
propositions invite également à
désengorger les métropoles pour
revitaliser les villes moyennes
ici au sénat bien sûr nous applaudissons
cette stratégie d'aménagement du
territoire mais dans le cadre précis de
la crise sanitaire pourriez vous nous
préciser sur quels éléments elles se
fondent car par exemple pour prendre
l'exemple de taïwan le minimum de mort a
été atteint dans des zones record de
densité une métropolisation cela bien
sûr à aiguiser notre curiosité
ma prochaine question est peut-être plus
compliqué puisqu'elle a trait aux
capacités de prospective de l'état et
vous êtes particulièrement donc bien
placés ici pour répondre
quel est d'après vous quelles sont
d'après vous les limites actuelles de
l'état stratège au site et avec un brin
de nostalgie il avance prise dont tant
par la france dans les technologies de
l'information avec eux le minitel mais
la vision de la française d'un
ordinateur central avec des terminaux a
été pour le moins bousculé par
l'ordinateur personnel cela illustre la
difficulté de la prospective et sans
doute l'absolue nécessité d'écouter très
largement les entrepreneurs les
territoires les forces vives de notre
pays qui sont au plus près des réalités
des aspirations
quelle est pour vous la place des autres
acteurs ou de la de l'état lui-même et
de son bras armé qui aujourd'hui le haut
commissariat au plan
accompagné de france stratégie dans la
définition de la stratégie économique du
pays
enfin cela sera mon dernier point vous
soulignez dans votre rapport le risque
détention intergénérationnel
pouvez vous nous expliquer la teneur de
vos craintes et quelle est votre vision
des conséquences des évolutions
démographiques de long terme pour
l'avenir de la france et de l'europe
voilà j'étais trop longue vous
donne la parole monsieur le haut
commissaire pour un propos liminaire et
ensuite l'ensemble de mes collègues
peuvent se manifester pour poser des
questions merci beaucoup et merci de
m'avoir invité j'y suis extrêmement
sensible
je vais vous en parlait dans une minute
en vous exposant l'idée que je me fais
de la méthode qu'il faut suivre alors un
panorama très rapide
deux de ceux que je pense que le blanc
entre guillemets doivent être d'abord
pour rappeler que
[Musique]
moi je me suis battue depuis 15 ans
autour de cette nécessité qui à mon avis
est est impérieuse pour reprendre
l'adjectif que le général de gaulle lui
a collé de cette obligation à dante qui
est celle pour un pays comme le nôtre
c'est à dire une nation et un état
d'arriver à se représenter ce que sont
les exigences de l'avenir à moyen et
long terme
j'ai écrit beaucoup de livres est à peu
près dans chacun de ces livres quand il
était consacrée à la politique je
défendrai cette nécessité en indiquant
que ce quand j'observe le monde est une
chose qui me frappe c'est que un pays
comme la chine et dieu sait que je
partage pas toutes les orientations du
gouvernement et aider et de la force
politique qui ne fait qu là avec lui en
chine mais la chine couverte à 30 ans il
y à une réflexion continuelle
prospective sur ce que les nécessités
vont être et peut-être sans vouloir
exagérer
peut-on considérer les achats de terre
un peu partout dans le monde comme une
de ses
application d'une vision stratégique à
très long terme
ugg ouvert là trente ans nous nous
gouvernons à 30 jours et encore on
connaît tous l'état la manière dont
l'état fonctionne dont les gouvernements
fonctionne successifs et la pression de
l'actualité la pression de l'urgence est
évidemment l'élément déterminant pour la
prise de décisions au sommet quelles que
soient les sommets et quelles que soient
les temps parce que l'opinion publique
les sondages enfin tout cela que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi est
extrêmement prévenant et donc je
toujours trouvé que c'était une erreur
absolue que d'avoir supprimé rayer d'un
trait de plume ou en tout cas fait
entrer dans une
comment je pourrais lire une non une
obscurité bienveillante
ce travail de ce travail de prospective
et donc je me suis beaucoup battu autour
de cette idée j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
de conversations avec le président de la
république sur ce point et puis quand
est arrivée la crise du cornât virus que
nous avons vécu dès le début de l'année
au printemps à ce moment là il est
apparu à mes yeux et aux yeux du
président de la république
on était dans une situation
d'impréparation tout le monde dit on
n'avait pas prévu la crise du
coronavirus c'est pas tout à fait exact
la crise du coronavirus elle était
parfaitement décrite dans le livre blanc
de la défense en 2008 et avait quasiment
à la ligne et au mot près la description
de ce que pourrait être la menace sur un
pays comme la france
d'une épidémie pulmonaire virale je dois
dire que moi j'ai toujours pensé toute
ma vie que ça pourrait se produire parce
que j'avais beaucoup étudié la grippe
espagnole où tant et tant de des plus
éminents esprit français sont partis je
rappelle entre 30 et 50 millions de
morts donc et dont j'ai toujours pensé
que ça arrivait mais j'ai dit l'autre
jour à la radio pour battre ma coulpe
que j'avais jamais imaginé la
désorganisation mondiale que ça
provoquerait est donc cette question de
de la prospective ou en tout cas
l'introduction des grandes questions
d'avenir même lointain dans la décision
immédiate
c'est une question qui m'est toujours
apparu absolument crucial
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on a vu
pendant les pieds l'épidémie de
coronavirus on a vu que tout d'un coup
pour nous qui par exemple pour nous qui
sommes nous qui croyons être un des
premiers pays au monde pour notre
organisation de la médecine
on a vu qu'on a été menacé de rupture
d'approvisionnement sur les molécules
les plus essentiels j'en cite cinq on
s'est trouvé en menace de rupture
d'approvisionnement pour les molécules
des traitement chimio pour le cancer
on s'est trouvé en menace de rupture
d'approvisionnement pour les molécules
destinées à l'anesthésié
on a parlé du curragh je crois qu'il y
en a d'autres on s'est trouvé en menace
de rupture d'approvisionnement pour les
corticoïdes pour les antibiotiques et
même pour le paracétamol
c'est dire à quel point nous avons tout
d'un coup vérifier non pas que nous
étions fragile mais que nous étions
fragile en situation de crise et pour ma
part j'ai c'en est un exemple de plus
j'ai toujours été admiratif de ce que
faisait les militaires en terme de
préparation à la défense face à des
menaces pour l'instant non encore
réalisés mais potentiel on a vu ça et
puis alors tentons quand on se pose
cette question qui est la porte d'entrée
qu'a voulu le président de la république
dans sept ans la création de ce
commissariat où la re création de ce
commissariat
on a donc pris la question sous l'angle
de la souveraineté car un pays comme le
nôtre avec à la fois son potentiel et
son histoire et le
l'attachement si grand qu'il a son
indépendance ou qu'il devrait avoir
encore davantage à son indépendance
ce pays là naturellement il ne peut pas
ignorer ce que sont les domaines de sa
vie qui peuvent se trouver brutalement
mis en cause s'il ya une crise parce
qu'ils dépendent de décisions lointaine
je pense à l'extrême orient par exemple
et donc je ça a été le je pense que ça a
été une des raisons qui ont fait que
nous président de la république a décidé
que que oui décidément n'allait recréer
ce type de réflexion à destination du
débat public des citoyens qui sont les
vrais patrons et les décideurs qui en
sont le relais plus ou moins bien avisés
et plus ou moins courageux selon les
périodes
voilà le contexte
alors quelle méthode allons nous suivre
vous avez commencé par cette phrase
madame la présidente
en dix ans la france est championne du
monde de la production de rapports
c'est plus que ça
après deux mois d'exercice de de ce
travail c'est plus que ça elle est
championne du monde deux compétences non
utilisés les rapports qui dès que signé
par vous pour pour les pour les
assemblées dès que sortie des deux
france tratégie par exemple du conseil
économique et social ces rapports la
s'entassent sur des rayons des
bibliothèques et sont immédiatement
oubliées ou en tout cas retrouve
immédiatement l'ombre et le silence qui
fait que personne
vous en avez des exemples des centaines
d'exemples vous même par votre
production mais personne ne peut au fond
on utilise ce gisement de ressources
mais ya pas que ça il ya des chercheurs
par centaines qu'on interroge jamais je
parlais récemment avec un très grand
responsable industriel d'il ya quelques
années
dix à huit ou dix ans qui a joué un rôle
majeur il me disait mais vous savez
c'est la première fois qu'on me demande
mon avis depuis dix ans les chercheurs
vous parliez du terrain des
entrepreneurs eux aussi on leur demande
pas souvent leur avis alors dans le
monde idéal que je porte de
dans la conception de cette fonction je
voudrais que toutes ses compétences
soient soient mises en exploitation si
j'ose dire que cette que ces mines
différentes soit mise en exploitation
alors vous m'interrogez sur les moyens
aux mes moyens sont extrêmement faibles
parce que j'ai choisi qu'il en soit
ainsi
le modèle qui est le mien c'est celui
que j'emmenais mis en place après la
guerre quand le général de gaulle lui a
confié cette responsabilité si
importante et s'agissant des deux
personnalités de monnaie de gaulle qui
n'étaient pas toujours d'accord mais qui
cependant je rappelle que monet était
membre du gouvernement à alger du
général de gaulle à alger et que c'était
lui qui était occupée lors de la
première guerre et de la seconde guerre
mondiale de l'approvisionnement et de
l'organisation de l'approvisionnement
notamment en armes de des forces
françaises donc je n'étais pas toujours
d'accord mais en tout cas monnaie à me
semble-t-il
en tout cas ouvert la voie vers ce que
doit être une organisation extrêmement
légère ne mobilisant pas de moyens
importants
j'imagine que nous serons je suis
entouré d'eric terre qui est le
secrétaire général et de philippe le
gars qui est le rapporteur général de
cette petite organisation que nous avons
construite au maximum on sera une
quinzaine quelque chose comme ça mais ce
ce que j'imagine c'est que l'on puisse
être en contact j'allais dire un team
comme jean monnet le faisait avec tous
ceux qui sont les hauts-fonds les
acteurs ou qui pourraient être les
acteurs de cette réflexion de long terme
les industriels les chercheurs moi par
exemple je suis toujours estomaqué de
voir j'ai eu des responsabilités dans ce
domaine
autrefois que l'université est
absolument déconnecté avec ses règles
ses chercheurs de la réflexion publique
or tous les autres pays du monde
évidemment les états unis évidemment la
grande bretagne évidemment l'allemagne
font que
sans parler de la chine ou du japon font
que la recherche et l'université c'est
le même monde chez eux notamment de
séparer chez nous mais c'est le même
monde chez eux en raison des grands
organismes s'est séparé c'est le même
monde chez eux et ça sert puissamment à
la réflexion publique donc mettre en
exploitation mettre en synergie m en
symphonie toutes les images que vous
voudrez ce très grand gisement de de
travaux déjà élaboré et de compétences
parmi ses compétences il y en a trois
avec qui je compte particulièrement
travaillé j'ai déjà je suis déjà allé
trois fois devant le conseil économique
et social parce que le conseil
économique et social est fait pour ça
fait d'ailleurs contemporain la création
du conseil économique et social et la
création du plan ses contemporains c'est
dans le même esprit c'est que la société
civile organisée comme comme se plaisent
à dire les responsables et les membres
du conseil économique et social la
société civile organisée doit être un
des interlocuteurs où un des cadres de
ce travail
deuxièmement il ya les commissions de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
c'est pourquoi je vous suis
particulièrement reconnaissant de
m'avoir invité
est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes des
producteurs de rapports vous aussi vous
êtes des gisements de compétences et je
veux pas m'avancer en disant qu' il doit
vous arrivé de penser que ces
compétences sont pas aussi utilement
mise en oeuvre que vous le souhaiteriez
et donc
et donc je compte beaucoup travailler
avec vous et avec et avec la commission
compétente de l'assemblée nationale on
est devant une réflexion en jachère sur
ce sujet et c'est étrange parce que
c'est pas du tout dans l'esprit alors je
vais dire ça avec beaucoup de diplomatie
si vous lisez les mémoires de monnaie
vous apercevrez que la commune que la
création du commissariat au plan le
commissariat général au plan
nathan enthousiasmé tout le monde dans
l'appareil dans l'organisation de l'état
et il me semble que c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui est encore d'actualité
je n'ai pas aperçu del en particulier de
pour les pour les mises à dispositions
nécessaires et tout ça tout ça est
absolument humains et vous m'interrogez
sur les rapports avec l'état
je dis non seulement que c'est
absolument humain mais que franchement
ils ont bien tort de craindre qu'il y
ait quelques empiètement que ce soit
alors je m'empresse de dire je n'ai pas
de compétence sur le plan de relance est
d'ailleurs je ne souhaite pas en avoir
parce que naturellement bercy le trésor
[Musique]
a tous les moyens du monde pour prendre
ces orientations
si je peux je suggérerais j'essaierai de
d'avoir un peu d' influence mais je
pense que ce serait une erreur pour
cette institution recréer de chercher du
pouvoir c'est pas du pouvoir qu'il faut
trouver le pouvoir c'est du domaine de
l'exécutif
ce que je cherche moi c'est que ces
questions d'avenir soit réimplanter dans
le débat et que nous puissions en les
traitant ou en les élucidant ou en les
éclairant avoir de l' influence est
influencée pouvoir ça n'est pas la même
chose
et donc c'est pour moi très très très
important alors maintenant j'en viens
aux questions que vous avez posé alors
comme vous savez pour certains d'entre
vous j'ai passé une très grande partie
de ma vie publique à m'inquiéter des
questions de dette et de déficit et à
conduire des campagnes compris
présidentielle différentes reprises pour
mettre en garde contre la désinvolture
qui était celle de notre société en face
de ces questions alors je vais essayer
de dire les choses avec prudents et
nuancent haut
aujourd'hui tout a changé on est nous
aurons été contemporain pourrait
raconter ça à vos petits enfants nous
aurons été contemporain d'un changement
absolu du mode de pensée des économistes
sur la question de la monnaie et de la
dette
j'avais l'autre jour une réunion avec
jean tirole le prix nobel d'économie et
olivier blanchard qui vous savez a été
l'économiste en chef du fmi
je disais moi j'ai été à un zélateur de
blanchard 1 je retrouve aujourd'hui
en phase avec blanchard 2 sauf que
blanchard et blanchard de ce n'était pas
du tout le même mode de pensée olivier
blanchard était un défenseur comme un
certain nombre d'entre nous comme moi
d'une orthodoxie assez strictes en
matière de dette et se trouve
aujourd'hui parmi ceux qui pensent que
le problème c'est complètement déplacé
et qu'il faut l'aborder d'une manière
différente et ma conviction c'est que
personne ne sait exactement comment
l'aborder pourquoi parce que les banques
centrales ont changé de paradigme
qu'elles ont décidé à la suite de la
réserve fédérale américaine que
l'important était dans l'alimentation de
l'économie en capacité de 2
financement que pour ça elles ont
pratiqué sous toutes ses formes
les taux les plus bas possibles jusqu'au
taux zéro et jusqu'au taux négatifs les
quantitative easing
quand ce n'est pas une défense deux
hélicoptères monnaie comme comme vous
savez tout cela aux mieux que moi
simplement et donc le bilan de ces
banques centrales est devenu ce que ce
que vous savez qu'il est là mais
évidemment la création monétaire elle
n'est pas seulement dans dans les
banques commerciales dépendant des
banques centrales la création des terres
elle est aujourd'hui plus large on
considère que pour un dollar
créé à partir des décisions que nous
évoquons des banques centrales y en a
deux qui sont créés dans un domaine
beaucoup plus mystérieux qui est
certains disent le shadow banking et
tout ça a créé des three lions 2 de
disponibilité et le mystère et que ça ne
crée pas d'inflation et même que ça
n'irrigue pas autant que nous le
voudrions l'économie est peut-être loin
de là alors vous savez quels sont les
ressorts secrets de cette de cette
mystérieuse de ce mécanisme mystérieux
c'est que lorsque des
des produits ou des facilités sont créés
les acteurs bancaires qui les créent
cherche à se garantir par du collatéral
le collatéral c'est
les bons du trésor américains c'est le
meilleur collatéral de la planète
il se trouve que ce que latéral n'est
pas très disponible et que d'une
certaine manière il y à un assèchement à
craindre ce qui fait que l'argent
n'irrigue pas on a ainsi des enfin vous
savez les chiffres mieux que moise
combien on dit 17 tri lion 10 7
milliards de milliards de dollars qui
qui qui ont été créés et qui trouve pas
donc une espèce de nuages macif de 2,9
et puis pas d'alimentation de l'économie
correspondante à cela si vous avez des
idées pour sortir de cette situation
vous me le dites je vous embauche faire
immédiatement parce que vous voyez bien
ce qu'ils gagnent et les banques
centrales ont à deux reprises au moins
essayer de remonter les taux la
catastrophe a été tel que ils ont fait
marche arrière et tout le monde comprend
quand vous avez un portefeuille à taux
zéro et que les banques centrales
remontent leurs taux votre portefeuille
est immédiatement dévalorisé et donc
dans votre bilan de banques de grandes
institutions
cette capacité là elle se trouve
immédiatement d'évaluer donc panique
alors c'est pas très bien quelle est la
solution parce que c'est apparemment une
situation dont à ma connaissance
personne sur la planète ne sait
aujourd'hui comment sortir donc on est
devant un nouveau modèle un paradigme
sans précédent et le leu françois bayrou
qui serait venu devant vous il ya dix
ans alors avait des idées absolument
granitique sur la dette les garanties
qu'on doit apporter qu'on doit toujours
finir par les payer que est aujourd'hui
j'observe les choses je lis autant que
je peux je parle avec les plus grands
spécialistes autant que je peux qui sont
pas si nombreux que ça je pense que nous
sommes dans un univers d'incertitude
or bonne univers d'incertitude
ça veut dire une chose évidente c'est
que il est très difficile d'investir et
voilà la situation de la première vous
avez interrogé sur sur la dette la
première devant laquelle nous sommes
alors je vais dire des choses qu on me
reprochera donc je les dis avec
avec humilité prudence et humour
est-ce que je pense que la cession de
participations de l'état est à l'échelle
de ce que je suis en train de décrire
peut-être pas vraiment si vous avez
compris ce que j'ai dit je suis pas
comme un responsable de la réserve
fédérale qui disait dans une conférence
de presse si vous avez compris ce que
j'ai dit ce que je me suis mal exprimé
mais ça n'est pas ce n'est pas moi ce
n'est pas ma position mais non je ne
suis pas du tout sûr quant à la
mobilisation de l'épargné pour mobiliser
l'épargné
je pense que ça doit être beaucoup plus
du côté de la consommation
parce que pour mobiliser les pagnes pour
l'investissement quand vous avez des
prêts à 0 % d'une certaine manière c'est
pas un c'est pal c'est pas la voie la
plus la plus facile à suivre en revanche
le jour où on pourra convaincre nos
concitoyens de consommer ça sera très
bien le problème c'est que ils sont dans
les mêmes il constate les mêmes
incertitudes que les autres et que donc
la certitude ça ne pousse ni à
l'investissement mais à la consommation
ça veut dire qu'il ya des
deux des moteurs de l'économie qui sont
évidemment dans une situation critique
alors ça se double en france pardonnez
moi de vous le dire c'est un élu du sud
ouest qui dit ça ça se double en france
du fait que nous sommes atteints dans
des secteurs qui sont des secteurs
vitaux pour nous je pense l'aéronautique
par exemple et au drame et à la
catastrophe que nous sommes en train de
vivre de ce point de vue là et donc tout
ce qui peut être fait pour parier sur
l'avenir sur des moteurs sur des moteurs
verts sur des carburants verts
donc tous ceux qui produisent de la
matière végétale sont évidents
évidemment en première ligne les
agriculteurs aussi de ce point de vue là
vous m'avez interrogé sur le télétravail
avec les risque de désocialisation ils
sont réels sont réels mais alors je
j'élargis un peu mon mont en champ de
réflexion de vision beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ont pensé pense encore et
des décideurs que c'est une crise c'est
à dire une parenthèse que en a ouvert
une parenthèse et qu'on la refermera et
qu'on retrouvera le monde comme il était
ceci est très compliqué pas seulement
pour la dette comme je l'entends dire à
droite mais c'est très compliqué parce
que un monde si on nous avait dit ça il
ya un an
il ya dix mois personne n'aurait cru un
monde où on ne s'embrasse plus où on ne
se sert plus la main où on ne se
visitent plus où on ne voyage plus où
les échanges se trouve mise en cause
alors que le développement la dynamique
de développement de nos sociétés depuis
deux siècles c'est l'augmentation
constante exponentielle et
l'élargissement consent constant
exponentielle des échanges et c'est ça
qui se trouve menacée
est ce que c'est un changement passagers
honnêtement je ne sais pas si ça dure et
peut si on trouve un vaccin d'ici très
peu de temps sans doute
je peux arriver à comprendre mais je
suis pas sûr qu'on aura les réponses
très rapide et peut-être en est en train
ça induit quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre d'un changement
pardon de le dire comme ça
anthropologique quelque chose de profond
qui est peut-être en train de se passer
et ce quelque chose de profond va
toucher le travail
naturellement et le télétravail à des
risques de désocialisation il ya des
risques de dubé risation si je puis
m'exprimer comme ça autour desquels il
va falloir que nous travaillons beaucoup
parce que s'il ya des risques du bir
isation se trouve devant la question des
garanties qu d'habitude de le contrat de
travail et le salariat à porte à porte
aux travailleurs et vous voyez bien que
on se trouve là encore devant des
situations qui sont très lourdes et nous
allons beaucoup travailler au plan sur
ce sujet vous m'avez à très juste titre
et je vous en remercie chaleureusement
parler d'aménagement du territoire alors
vous prenez par les sentiments donc je
vous en donne acte mais je pense que
nous nous trouvons absolument au
rendez-vous quand certain nombre d'entre
nous ont annoncé depuis des années des
années 2 delà de la nécessité de
reprendre cette question d'aménagement
du territoire
pourquoi parce que les grandes unités
urbaines ce
on vécu leur fragilité en face du
confinement les grandes unités urbaines
ont découvert que c'est probablement la
panacée n'était pas là alors vous
m'opposer à yoann je ne suis pas
absolument sûr que ce soit le modèle que
les français veulent suivre
et donc cette question de la
métropolisation croissante des sociétés
dans lesquelles nous sommes je pense
qu'elle va se poser en termes nouveaux
parce qu'on avait d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
déjà vécu ça avec les gilets jaunes
il y a aussi dans la société et je la
crois essentiel une demande de
d'équilibré du territoire
the
j'ai beaucoup ri parce que dès que j'ai
été nommé j'avais dit au président de la
république
on va faire une toute petite équipe mais
j'en mettrais une petite tard à pau
alors c'est pas parce que c'est possible
je suis capable de dire que c'est beau
mais c'est parce que je pense nécessaire
de montrer qu'on peut avoir une
participation depuis la province et même
la province réputée lointaines aux
réflexions centrale
il faut pas être sûr sur les sur les 50
hectares autour de la scène pour pour
participer à la réflexion du pays et
même ça se vivre est différemment on est
quelques-uns à avoir une expérience
d'élu local ici on vivrait différemment
si tout le monde pensait que on peut
depuis nos villes qui ont un
enracinement une histoire et même depuis
le monde rural participer à la vie du
pays y compris dans sa dimension
intellectuelle et vous voyez que tout ça
est très lié vous parliez de télétravail
c'est très lié à la numérisation et au
numérique
de même que un sujet que vous n'avez pas
abordé mais que je compte beaucoup
abordé qui est celui de la réforme de
l'état
nous sommes devant
là encore une capacité de changements
immenses et non réalisé un potentiel de
changement positif pour la société avec
un état qui sera si je puis exprimé un
voeu de moins en moins bloquant et
autobloquant et de plus en plus soutient
des initiatives y compris des siennes
propres
de ce point de vue là la crise nous
plonge dans la nécessité dans
l'obligation de reprendre à frais
nouveaux des réflexions que qui ont déjà
été conduites et et nous comptons bien y
participer
et donc oui il n'ya pas seulement la
question de désengorger c'est que
peut-être notamment avec le confinement
dont concitoyens ont compris qu'ils
avaient d'autres modes de vie que la
métropolisation galopante
je vais finir par votre dernière
question parce qu'elle est pour moi la
plus préoccupante
en effet nous avons dans ce rapport qui
est le premier que nous allons fournir
on va
d'ici quelques semaines en produire
d'autres notamment sur la démographie
puisque vous m'avez interrogé sur ce
sujet que je considère comme un sujet
essentiel
il n'y a pas de vitalité d'un pays
s'il n'est pas capable d'avoir une
vision positive de sa démographie et
donc vous m'avez interrogé sur les
risques de tensions inter
générationnelle alors je n'emploie pas
le mot tension au sens où on utilise
habituellement sur ce sujet mais je sens
qu'il y à une question lourde
du côté de
la vision que nous proposons plus jeunes
pour leur avenir
ça je trouve ça très préoccupant
lorsqu'on à 17 18 20 ans 21 ans 23 ans
et que l'univers qu'on vous propose
c'est le confinement justifié
sanitairement un jeu de passes en cause
vous le comprenez bien et aucune porte
pour entrer sur le marché du travail
alors il ya là quelque chose qui est
risqué je m'inquiète de ce point de vue
là je m'inquiète parce que ça fait des
décennies qu'il n'y a pas eu de discours
de langage de projets qui atteignent
directement les plus jeunes et il peut
se faire aussi qu'un certain nombre de
ces projets soient des impasses et donc
le si j'avais alors je conclus sur cela
j'ai une certitude et une réserve à
cette certitude
ma certitude c'est qu'on va s'en sortir
un pays comme le nôtre avec son
potentiel sa capacité les atouts qui
pourraient être les siens un pays comme
le nôtre va s'en sortir et ma réserve
c'est sur les plus jeunes on va s'en
sortir vous avez lu peut-être les
propositions que nous avons faites
j'ai parlé de notre dépendance sur sur
les aspects de notre vie qui touche à la
souveraineté
les médicaments et puis bien d'autres
sujets par exemple sur un certain nombre
de composants électroniques bon donc les
questions de dépendance
nous allons essayer de décrire et on en
parlera avec vous un plan pour retrouver
l'indépendance sur ses secteurs
d'activité sans lesquels nous ne pouvons
pas vivre et sur lesquels nous devons
avoir à l'image de ce que la défense
nationale a produit pendant 150 ans un
plan de mobilisation s'il ya une crise
et donc premier sujet j'ai un deuxième
sujet qui est naturellement un sujet de
préoccupation on a comme vous l'avez
noté remarquer y compris avec un peu
d'ironie dans le regard
on a puissamment soutenu le modèle
social qui est le nôtre pour n'être en
train tous les jours
par des injections de milliards de
soutenir le modèle social mais ceci
n'est pas durable si nous n'avons pas
l'appareil productif qui est capable de
soutenir par les taxes et les
cotisations ce modèle social là ce qui
fait que le deuxième chapitre de notre
action doit être quel plan de
reconstruction de notre appareil
productif pouvons-nous discuter ensemble
tous ensemble et peint avec biya qu un
des faucons
alors on a de ce point de vue là une
chance formidable c'est que on est à un
tournant de la production dans le monde
et ce tournant de la production il
il est naturellement centré autour d'eux
du numérique des dates à des algorithmes
et donc de la robotisation un certain
nombre d'industries qui étaient des
industries de main d'oeuvre était
évidemment projeter très loin
aujourd'hui avec bon d'ici peu on use in
rats plus de pièces on a des imprimantes
3d qui vont re est réalisé j'aurais
réalisé ces pièces là et c'est pas de la
science fiction c'est sais c'est tous
les jours dans nos unités de production
les plus avancées peut-être pouvons-nous
monter dans ce train là mieux que
d'autres parce que nous avons une
capacité de recherche dans le numérique
qui est plus forte dans les algorithmes
qui est plus forte dans l'utilisation
des data qui est plus forte que beaucoup
d'autres pays dans le monde
donc je vois ça je vois ce deuxième
aspect avec optimisme
de même que
l'équipement numérique du pays nous
sommes un des pays quand même les plus
avancés en équipement numérique et on va
aller jusqu'au bout et ça ne coûte pas
si cher quelques dizaines de milliards
alors qu'on va utiliser entre 500 et 700
milliards donc de ce point de vue là
donc de ce point de vue là je suis
habité par au fond un optimisme de
résilience je sais pas comment on peut
dire j'ai l'impression qu'on va mais il
ya cette question de la jeunesse qui
reste pour moi une réserve à laquelle
nous devons beaucoup réfléchir consacrer
beaucoup de notre intuition et de notre
empathie pour pouvoir renouer avec eux
et leur proposer des modèles qui ne
soient pas des impasses voilà pardon
d'avoir été trop long pour ce cet exposé
introductif
merci beaucoup sur le commissaire vous a
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention en tout
cas la salle est très calme je trouve
et du coup à l'habitude les plus agités
un petit peu plus voilà donc nous avons
beaucoup de 2 oui ça va venir pierre
nous avons beaucoup de demandes de
parole je vais commencer par évelyne
renou garabédian et ensuite franck mais
non ville merci madame la présidente
monsieur le corps le haut commissaire il
y a quelques semaines france stratégie a
publié une note d'excusé moi je ne vois
pas je demande à mon collègue de
s'avancer de circuler merci donc merci
qui a publié une note d'étape sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté et notamment
pendant la période coronavirus ce
rapport insiste sur le fait que la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons
aujourd'hui révèle des manques de nos
politiques publiques en matière de lutte
contre la pauvreté et combien le
logement se trouve être au milieu est au
coeur de ce dispositif
nous savons tous ensemble que cette
crise sanitaire va à court terme portée
des fortes des fortes demandes d'emploi
il va y avoir des chutes de pertes
d'emplois il va y avoir des faillites en
masse il va y avoir des secteurs entiers
d'activités qui vont disparaître et
certaines catégories de la population
frôle aujourd'hui la pauvreté la
situation actuelle de certains
travailleurs indépendants le montre
d'ailleurs comme jean monnet l'a
expliqué le plan ne décide pas il
oriente pouvez vous monsieur le haut
commissaire nous indiquer comment vous
envisagez d'orienter les options du
gouvernement pour éviter à tous ces
individus ne se trouvait dans une
situation de précarité et qui comme vous
le savez de laquelle on se redresse très
difficilement merci de vos réponses
si vous permettez prendre plusieurs
questions je vais donner la parole à
franck mais non ville ensuite à serge
babary et ensuite ils boulot et je vous
laisse répondre merci madame la
présidente monsieur le commissaire de
haut commissaire tout d'abord permettez
moi de vous remercier et féliciter deux
de vos propos absolument passionnant et
vous aussi de vous dire que c'était
attendu la création de ce haut
commissaire pour ceux au commissariat
pour effectivement nous inscrire dans
une stratégie prospective de moyen et
long terme ce qui est absolument
nécessaire moi j'ai quelques questions à
vous poser donc les vous avez évoqué
peut-être vous vous demandez tout
d'abord comment comptez vous associez
donc au travail qui est le vôtre
les collectivités territoriales et en
particulier les régions qui sont bien
évidemment au coeur de cette de ces
stratégies économiques mais également de
d'aménagement du territoire et qui
doivent elles aussi s'inscrire dans le
moyen et long terme aussi peut-être
votre action on l'a bien compris
s'inscrit aussi sur les enjeux de
souveraineté donc peut-être que vous
puissiez évoqué les enjeux de
souveraineté notamment numériques qui
est absolument
stratégique et puis peut-être aussi
quelle place aura l'agriculture et la
bioéconomie qui là aussi est un axe
stratégique et d'avenir voilà et
peut-être une dernière question sur le
sur le rôle qu'il sera le vôtre sur la
promotion et je vais dire les
propositions matière de quel champ de
réflexion vous aurez en matière de
réformes structurelles de notre pays est
ce que c'est une mission qui vous est
confiée voire même d'évolution
institutionnelle
merci franck la parole est temps au
président de la délégation aux
entreprises serge barba babar et ensuite
ils boulot merci président monsieur haut
commissaire merci tout d'abord de nous
avoir fait partager au début de votre
prise de fonction votre vision
stratégique
elle nous apporte évidemment plus haut
point et on est tous disposés à
participer à s'intéresser à vos travaux
je souhaite évoquer un sujet de vue une
extrême actualité la numérisation
vous l'avez évoqué à plusieurs reprises
les nouvelles façons de travailler le
télétravail vous en avais dit amour une
nouvelle forme de commerce c'est un
sujet du jour il s'agit de la couverture
numérique du territoire
ça concourt à l'aménagement du
territoire et de l'appropriation du
numérique par nos concitoyens 13
millions de personnes pour des raisons
diverses n'ont pas accès à l'internet
il s'agit aussi de la numérisation des
entreprises un tiers des entreprises
tout particulièrement les tpe et les
commerces n'ont pas accès internet
on mesure cette lacune pour la
continuité de l'activité économique et
du et commerciale en ce moment même vous
avez évoqué ces problèmes
ces problématiques dans votre note
l'ouverture du 28 octobre dernier et ce
matin même pouvez vous nous indiquer
monsieur le haut commissaire vos
réflexions et préconisations dans ce
domaine essentiel pour l'avenir et la
modernisation notre société je vous
remercie
merci pour finir cette première série
boulot oui merci madame la présente
présidente monsieur le haut commissaire
avant tout je vous félicite pour vos
propos très intéressant je souhaiterais
vous entendre sur un sujet brûlant
d'actualité immédiate
le nouveau confinement fait que les
commerces de proximité
déjà très fragilisé risques pour
beaucoup d'entre eux de fermer malgré
les aides du gouvernement
c'est un enjeu crucial pour notre pays
et pour la population des territoires
ruraux toujours plus lésés en matière
d'accès au commerce
monsieur le haut commissaire avez-vous
déjà réfléchi à des solutions à court ou
moyen terme pour vous c'est plutôt moyen
et long terme
pour autant je pense que cet intéressant
néanmoins pour donc réfléchir sur ses
solutions pour sauver les commerces de
proximité
merci merci monsieur le haut commissaire
je peux peut-être laissé répondre à ses
premières prestations de questions prêts
faciles que vous avez vu
et je les aborde si vous permettez pas
seulement dans ses fonctions la mets
dans mes autres fonctions de maire et de
président d'une communauté
d'agglomération et je n'oublie pas que
j'ai été président de conseil général
aussi donc je monde à bord sera aussi
bien locales que prospectifs la question
la plus difficile c'est évidemment celle
de madame reno garabédian pour aller
droit au but je pense comme vous qu'il
va falloir que nous réfléchissions à
d'autres approches de lutte contre la
pauvreté et dans tous ses aspects j'ai
lancé à pau une opération il ya déjà
plusieurs années que je trouve très
intéressante qui est un plan anti
solitude pour l'inciter parce que la
solitude étant des aspects de la
pauvreté et une pauvreté et la solitude
peut être parfois plus cruelle en ville
y compris sur sur le palier de son
appartement parce que et je pense que la
prise en charge de tous les moyens de
lutter contre la solitude je vais donner
un exemple ou de à est une manière de
lutter contre la pauvreté
j'ai défendu ça j'ai défendu sa dans une
dans une campagne présidentielles
antérieures
je m'étais fait la réflexion suivante
une personne seule avec 700 euros c'est
la misère totale
deux personnes avec les mêmes 700 euros
ça fait 1400 euros c'est déjà un peu
plus facile mais trois personnes avec
700 euros ça fait 2000 100 euros et on
arrive dans une espèce de cellule
familiale de cellules de de vie en
commun on arrive à faire la cuisine
trouvaient des approvisionnements
simplement notre système social
il est construit contre des solutions de
cet ordre
dès l'instant que vous alors pardon là
je suis pas en train de faire le le
commissaire au plan je suis en train de
faire le citoyen qui réfléchit la
question
notre système est entièrement construit
pour empêcher cela j'avais
je sais tout à fait le moment où je me
suis rendu compte avec tristesse de la
situation il y avait une
une dame d'âge mûr elle était en couple
avec non non non non non non non non non
non non non non non non en fait pas du
tout elle avait 60 ans et son mari est
mort
il était tout l'été de son mari et est
au rsa et elle a recueilli chez elle son
beau père il y avait dans 80 et ils ont
d'une certaine manière passer ce cap
difficile et les choses allaient pas
trop mal simplement les organismes
sociaux ou couper les allocations
puisque le t2 pour vivre ensemble ils
ont coupé les allocations et donc le
beau père est reparti dans il habitait
une caravane les reparti on l'a rétabli
les allocations et elle est restée tout
seul et tous les deux avaient 700 euros
et c'était 2 misère alors que ça aurait
pu faire quelque chose de plus un
et vous voyez le changement de
perspective que cela impose j'ai donc
travaillé avec les organismes sociaux à
pau pour permettre ce genre de
colocation de cohabitation de manière de
vivre ensemble sans qu'on coupe les
allocations et on en est un
plusieurs locations comme ça on a
travaillé avec les bailleurs sociaux n'a
ce sont des approches différentes et
j'insiste sur le fait qu'elle ne coûte
pas un euro de plus mais on apporte des
réponses qui sont des réponses
différentes et plus humaine sur les
situations que nous avons que nous avons
ainsi à découvrir ensemble face à
l'extrême pauvreté on s'en tirent pas
tout seul et la puissance publique
pousse à la solitude et cette nouvelle
approche
encore une fois je défends comme citoyen
c'est ses traits en tout cas pour moi
c'est prometteur
et là comme ailleurs je pense qu'on peut
faire mieux sans dépenser plus alors
sans compter que il n'ya pas de
logements bien entendu j'ai la chance
d'habiter une zone qui n'est pas en
tension mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
logements disponibles en france il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'appartements de
maisons inhabitées et ça rejoint
l'aménagement du territoire qu'on
évoquait à l'instant mais ça rejoint
aussi la question de l'appareil
productif parce que s'il n'y a que la
misère sans appareil productif alors et
vous voyez l'immense tâche que nous
avons devant nous
monsieur mêlant ville
alors les cool les comment travailler
avec les collectivités territoriales
alors hein
c'est une question que je considère
comme vital pour la société
le si on comparait j'ai fait ça cet
exercice un jour le nombre de lignes
dans les journaux consacrés à ce qui se
passe parmi les
65 millions d'habitants non parisiens
avec le nombre de lignes consacrées aux
deux millions d'habitants parisien est
encore parmi ces deux millions il y en a
que deux cent mille d'antan dont on
parle et qu'on écrivain c'est l'univers
people politico médiatique il ya que ça
qu'on écrit alors vous apercevez que
probablement le contingent de ligne des
1 et 100 fois plus important que le
comté jeudi sans probablement suis-je au
dessous de la vérité
les contingents de l'idée autres
seraient quilibre âge de la france alors
qu'il ya toutes les raisons historiques
que vous savez que nous savons pour moi
il est vital encore faudrait-il que les
collectivités territoriales fussent bien
composés équilibrée elle même je
m'exprime ici à titre absolument
personnelle mais vous vous dites comment
va travailler avec les régions le
ce qui vous regarde et le découpage des
régions y en a qui sont très bien et
d'autres qui sont impossibles contredire
mais on aurait dû voter contre
enfin de la situation n'est ce pas
prétendre que pau et dans la même région
que limoges que poitiers que brees
suivent
je veux dire faut faut jamais être allé
en france quoi un bon et donc et donc
c'est pour moi en tout cas cet équilibre
du travail en commun ne pourra être
trouvée que quand on aura les équilibres
de de la réalité des responsabilités de
tout et de tout c'est de toutes ces
choses là
donc oui je pense que on vient de le
voir dans la crise
quand ça va mal qu'est ce qui tient
c'est l'échelon de proximité
on a
voilà j'ai passé mon temps à chercher en
février des masques en aujourd'hui
comment on peut faire si les services
d'urgence se trouve
en explosion et c'est une et c'est une
grande richesse de pouvoir ainsi deux
prêts essayer de faire face et l'état ne
pourra pas faire autrement que de le
reconnaître même si'il rejab tout le
temps de dans un premier temps on va le
faire après ça se fait moi mais mais
c'est une absolue nécessité
alors ensuite la question du numérique
plusieurs questions ont été posées de ce
point de vue là
d'abord on a progressé pas mal et je
pense que l'équipement 5g va nous
permettre de faire un pas très important
et notamment pour les zones non
couvertes alors l'équipement 5g il ya
beaucoup de débats autour de cet
équipement je crois que à peu près tous
les experts s'accordent pour dire que
les les émetteurs en 5 g sont moins
préoccupant du point de vue de la
puissance d'émission et du point de vue
de la longueur d'onde que ne le sont les
émissions 4g et que ne l'étaient les
émissions des générations précédentes
donc ce débat là me semble-t-il devrait
être écartée je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
est moins fort qu'il ne l'était il ya
quelques temps mais en tout cas moi je
travaille avec les physiciens et
ils disent ça alors sans la moindre
hésitation de leur part je pense que ça
va être un pas très important et je
reprends l'affirmation qui est la vôtre
sur l'agriculture et la bioéconomie gs
qui sait tout à l'heure en parlant des
carburants verts notamment pour
l'aviation des voix 2 des voix 2 2
découvertes qui vont rendre à
l'agriculture une partie de sa fonction
y compris non alimentaire après
peut-être on va se trouver aussi devant
des questions de de capacités de
production et donc il ya là des choses
que chacun d'entre nous connaît et enfin
réformes structurelles j'ai dit que nous
allions travailler sur la question de
l'état
c'est c'est beaucoup plus facile quand
ça n'est pas quand la démarche de
travail sur ces sujets n'est pas une
démarche électorale je les ai conduite
sous forme électorale je sais les
polémiques qu'on peut faire d'être sur
ce sujet mais je vois bien que que que
l'état se trouve alors d'abord il est
extrêmement nécessaire quand ça va mal
mais il peut pas faire tout seul ils se
trouvent la plupart du temps ou assez
souvent en situation d'auto blocage
c'est lui même qui produit ses propres
blocage enfin c'est nous mêmes parce que
les normes
nous en sommes contempteurs d'un côté en
les critiques et nous en sommes
producteurs de l'autre on demande
constamment dès que ces normes
donc de ce point de vue là oui 1,2 à de
mes amis
brillant disait l'autre joue au fond il
ya deux chances que nous avons devant
nous le numérique et le développement
qui va être immense des capacités du
numérique et les réserves de
productivité de l'état parce que là
aussi il ya une mine inexploité alors
monsieur barry le commerce
au fond la réponse est probablement la
même nous avons construit un pot pas
tout à fait fini de construire enfin un
outil numérique qui permet aux gens
intéressés de visiter chacune des
boutiques du centre ville on promène son
avatar comme disent les ans promène son
avatar dans la rue il entre dans la
boutique et y voit le confit de canard
ou bien
les robes il peut commander en direct il
ya là une ressource je dis pas que c'est
la seule ressource mais il ya un
deuxième aspect des choses alors en
dehors des aspects les plus polémiques
de l'actualité je trouve que le modèle
des grandes surfaces est moins attrayant
pour les gens d'ailleurs les difficultés
économiques des grandes chaînes le
prouve
je pense que là encore il ya une demande
de deux sociétés à dimension humaine de
contact de rencontre de bon après ça
pose le problème des outils qu'on a et
notamment des foncières qui peuvent
permettre de une intervention dans le
domaine commercial
à condition qu'on arrive à équilibrer
ses outils et ses moyens et donc je
réponds pour la numérisation aussi bien
pour les français que pour les
entreprises trouvent que c'est un sujet
sur lequel je travaille depuis le début
des années 80 et donc ayant ayant
produit un journal numérique qui devrait
être à peu près le premier de 1983 je
rappelle qu'internet ses 94
je rappelle aussi je les fais dans le
rapport qu' il y avait eu une intuition
formidable des gouvernants de l'époque
qui était de proposer un terminal
numérique dans chaque foyer et c'était
une intuition magnifique essai sur ce
réseau qui était le réseau de
préfiguration du 10 août elle s'appelait
pas encore comme ça que j'ai produit
j'étais très jeune le premier journal
numérique
donc cette cette question là est une
question
fascinante parce que je rappelle que ce
qui a donné internet c'est un tout petit
nombre de chercheurs dont certains
étaient français qui avaient pensé le
qui avait pensé le langage qui a permis
internet
et puis comme toujours on était
précurseur et on participe pas aux
fruits de de la recherche
et ça ça pose une question sur l'état
aussi est sûre peut-être la mentalité de
notre pays et sur le fait qu'il n'y a
nulle part dans l'appareil de
gouvernance de l'état il ya nulle part
d'organisations qui s'occupe d'eux
d'encourager le développement de
l'innovation une fois que l'innovation a
été trouvé alors ça ne peut pas se faire
que par l'état se fait aussi avec
évidemment le monde de l'entreprise mais
vous voyez cette cette préoccupation n'a
qu' on cherche on trouve
et c'est d'autres qui cueille les fruits
et donc voilà les quelques lesquels
réponse je pense que la 5g est une
solution voilà en tout cas une partie de
la solution
on pressent de dire que on peut faire
autrement nous avons
à pau un réseau numérique fibré jeu qui
est arrivé chez tous les citoyens et à
toutes les adresses sur investissement
public et maintenant nous en récupérons
les fruits mais c'est une décision que
nous avons prise mois après comme
président du conseil général et andré
labarrère comme maire de pau à l'époque
ensemble il ya 20 ans il nous a fallu 20
ans pour y arriver et on est la seule
ville qui soit ainsi entièrement fibré
sur investissement public et on a le
retour sur investissement très bien
monsieur le commissaire je vais prendre
un petit peu plus de questions là parce
que vous êtes très nombreux jeux pas ou
trop longtemps ça je me permets très
pieux mais mes collègues sont très
curieux wells et voilà laurent duplomb
suite viviane artigalas merci madame la
présidente monsieur le haut commissaire
dans votre note que vous nous avez fait
passer au bout services nous ont fait
passer
j'ai retenu une phrase importante dans
le paragraphe une nouvelle façon d'être
au monde
cette phrase cette réduction drastique
des relations interpersonnelles
notamment entre personnes relevant de
catégories socioprofessionnelles
différentes et porteuse de menaces sur
la cohésion sociale on est en plein dans
la réalité de notre pays aujourd'hui la
problématique aujourd'hui monsieur le
haut commissaire c'est qu'on oppose trop
les ans les uns contre les autres on
oppose trop les professions les unes
contre les autres on oppose trop les
minorités contre des idées qui sont pas
obligatoirement faciles ou possible de
mettre en place dans certaines
professions et moi j'aurai une
recommandation à vous faire qui ne coûte
rien donc ça va vous intéresser puisque
le but c'est de dépenser le moins
d'argent possible c'est de redonner du
sens à la politique
le politique ne doit pas sombrer dans
ses messages là et malheureusement
depuis trois ans malgré l'histoire d'un
nouveau monde
on a énormément connu cela on a connu
cela à travers la loi et galim qui
engendrait encore un peu plus des
grilles mashing on a connu ça dans la
loi économie circulaire qui a engendré
encore un peu plus de plastique bashing
on a connu ça sur la suppression de
taxes la taxe d'habitation avec le
hashtag balances ton maire s'est pas
tenable si on continue d'opposer les
gens les uns contre les autres on aura
au bout du bout la disparition de la
cohésion sociale et ça aujourd'hui il
faut véritablement qu'on le prenne en
compte parce que c'est ça le vrai plan
de relance on peut mettre des millions
on peut mettre des milliards si on ne
redoute pas la capacité pour les gens de
comprendre ce que fait l'autre et
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi il le
fait plutôt que de le condamner sur
l'autel de l'obscurantisme ou d'avis
tout à fait marquer politiquement
eh bien on n'y arrivera pas alors je
vous donne cette proposition là parce
que je pense comme je vous le disais ne
coûte pas cher mais par contre elle
aiderait sérieusement notre pays dans la
situation dans laquelle il va se trouver
dans quelques mois merci laurent
vivienne artigalas ensuite patrick
chaize merci madame la présidente
monsieur de le haut commissaire nous
avons déjà beaucoup évoqué la question
du numérique et cela montre bien combien
ce développement du numérique est un
enjeu incontournable pour notre pays
nous avons dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sénatoriale sur l'électro
tisme insisté cependant sur la nécessité
de maintenir des accès d'hiver au
service public pour les usagers et de
garantir l'égalité d'accès dans les
territoires il faudrait garder une
diversité d'accès aux services publics à
destination de tous ceux qui pour des
raisons diverses ne peuvent se contenter
d'un recours exclusif aux sites aux
solutions numériques
nous avons ainsi suggéré la création
d'une filière de médiateur numériques
compétente à condition de leur garantir
pérennité et stabilité pour les pme été
pe il faudrait prévoir un accompagnement
spécifique pour qu'elles se forme au
numérique et s'équipent le plan de
relance de l'économie devrait prévoir
voulait consacrer un temps de formation
avec des moyens financiers prévus par
l'état
que pensez vous de ces propositions et
quelles pourraient être les vôtres sur
le long terme
merci merci viviane patrick chaize
ensuite fabien gay oui ma présente merci
monsieur le commissaire tout d'abord je
voudrais remercier évidemment pour votre
présence et pour vos propos tout aussi
dense qu'inquiétant pour ma part
j'espère un peu aussi
porteur d'espoir je souhaiterais
néanmoins donc revenir sur un sujet qui
m'est chère qui était déjà abordé par
nombre de mes collègues qui concerne le
numérique vous l'avez rappelé internet
est né en france il est né dans l'ain et
j'en suis donc le représentant un
compatriote
voilà plusieurs points au niveau du
numérique complémentaires le premier les
infrastructures vous l'avez exprimé avec
un bel exemple à pau un plan france très
haut débit a été mis en place
aujourd'hui il n'est pas encore
évidemment complet sur le territoire
national depuis plusieurs années ainsi
ce taux pour faire en sorte que ce plan
s'accélère dans le cadre du plan de
relance évidemment j'imagine
j'ai vu qu'il y avait à un volet mais il
faudrait qu'il soit vraiment
définitivement complet
deuxième sujet qui était déjà abordé par
mes collègues c'est l'inclusion
numérique et avec effectivement là aussi
des décisions importantes à prendre pour
faire en sorte que l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes puissent accéder à ce
service qui devient un service
indispensable et qui s'imposent à nous
on a parlé des plateformes avec cette
problématique qui est que ces
plateformes sont plutôt à l'extérieur de
notre pays on a un besoin de
souveraineté vous l'avez rappelé on a
aussi beaucoup parlé d' inégalité
fiscale vis-à-vis de ces plateformes
quel chantier allez vous ouvrir sur ce
point là avec à mon sens une besoin
d'accélération en tout cas un besoin
rapide d'apporter des réponses sur le
télétravail là aussi le télétravail peut
être une solution
on a parlé de problématiques sociales on
pourrait aussi de développer les espaces
dédiés c'est un homme une voix que j'ai
pas vu ouverte de façon enfin en tout
cas exprimé je pense que c'est important
de pouvoir le faire
enfin je voudrais finir sur le numérique
en disant que
nous sommes dans un monde de défiance a
été rappelé aussi dans d'autres sujets
vous avez évoqué donc été rassurant
plutôt ça sur la 5g je ne le suis pas du
tout on sent effectivement au sein de
compatriotes une inquiétude sur la 5g je
pense qu'il ya des problématiques
d'information peut-être de pédagogie sur
le sujet et puis le numérique ça aussi
des inconvénients notamment un
inconvénient environnementale puisque
donc le numérique peut poser de façon
importante
donc vous avez parlé de rapports tout à
l'heure et un excellent rapport
sénatorial sur l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique je pense
qu'il serait aussi important de le
prendre en compte rapidement pour faire
en sorte que le remède ne soit pas pire
que le mal
enfin et c'est mon dernier point
vraiment vous avez dans votre note
évoqué le retour du politique
de quelle manière vous voyez vous ça et
à quelle échéance
merci 6-4 et fabien gay ensuite joël
labbé en visio alors si madame la
présidente monsieur haut-commissaire moi
je vous rassure de suite je n'aurais pas
donnerait pas la solution sur la
question de la monnaie et du changement
de la banque centrale européenne sinon
vous seriez obligés de m'embaucher
et je pense que vous seriez en grande
difficulté jean c'est en grand non mais
sérieux j'ai un point d'accord avec vous
et un point de désaccord moins un point
d'accord je pense que la période que
nous sommes en train de traverser est
porteuse de doute et il nous faut douter
doute et non pas pour retarder les
échéances à ne pas prendre des décisions
douté parce que nous toutes et tous avec
nos différences politiques
elle nous oblige à nous interroger à
nous réinterroger pour construire des
solutions porteuses d'avenir et c'est
pour ça que j'ai lu avec attention votre
première note
il ya des choses extrêmement
intéressante vous lit y compris que je
peux partager mais il n'ya pas quand
j'ai fini de lire une rupture avec les
politiques telles qu'elles étaient
menées avant crise c'est à dire que vous
tracer un chemin qui est comme avant
c'est à dire dans des petits
s'inscrivent dans des politiques et des
logiques
que je qualifierais mois de libéral mais
après on peut avoir un point un point de
désaccord sur ça et donc je pense qu'on
a besoin d'ouvrir le deuxième point je
vous ai bien écoutez vous dites je
m'inscris dans ce haut commissariat je
n'ai pas de moyens mais il ya quand même
les équipes de france stratégie donc je
voudrais c'est bien confirmé que vous
avez les équipes de france tratégie et
je ne veux pas de pouvoir je veux de l'
influence comme ça et je ne veux pas
caricaturer vos propos mais en réalité
c'est le choix contraire monsieur le
haut commissaire parce que contrairement
monnaie et au général de gaulle en 46 où
il y avait des plans quinquennaux comme
ça qu'on les appelait et on s'appuyait
sur quoi un secteur bancaire nationalisé
au quasi nationalisé et des grandes
entreprises notamment qu'il y avait des
monopoles publics et avec lesquels on
aménageait le territoire sur une
question d'égalité républicaine
aujourd'hui c'est un choix contraint le
secteur bancaire complètement privatisée
et des monopoles et des grandes
entreprises publiques complètement
démantelée et donc en réalité vous avez
aucun levier
j'ai envie de le dire mais c'est pas
vous qui construisent dans cette salle
n'auraient aucun levier et dont vous
avez une question que je finis par là
sur la numérisation des entreprises moi
je partage ça mais par exemple ont un
problème
le leader aujourd'hui de surprenant
numériser les entreprises c'est
pagesjaunes sur le call ça fait quatre
ans qu'ils vivent des restructurations
et des plans sociaux et ils sont en
train de se faire aspirer par google et
le gouvernement ne fait rien rien et je
le dit les yeux dans les yeux j'ai été
je les accompagne et aux délégués à la
restructuration
on a été voir cédric haut et monsieur
match j'oublie avant est rien
donc en réalité on peut pousser sur la
numérisation des entreprises aujourd'hui
on n'a aucun outil industriel pour y
arriver
voilà la réalité quel est ton jeu
qu'elle est
vous avez fini je veux pas trop
longtemps traversé avait cité un an que
je n'ai pas compris s'ils ont la balle
jaune son local c'est le leader
aujourd'hui français de la création des
pages internet pour nos tpe pme c'est
l'ancien pages jaunes et qui à 95 %
aujourd'hui numérisées insérées entre
air de laisser ça partira google et le
gouvernement ne fait rien merci fabien
joël labbé qui est en visio sais pas si
tu es du morbihan ou dans les jardins du
luxembourg mais voilà on t'écoute joël
pourrait très bien très bien saisi sur
le long terme et aux mutations pour
moutier la jeunesse
comment redonner l'espoir à cette
jeunesse qui est quelque part en
enrichir ses collections dans la nuit je
souhaiterais votre point de vue sur deux
rapports ce que vous avez évoqué aussi
le fait que la france est championne du
monde des compétences gâcher je partage
alors qu'il y en a partout de présenter
là il ya moins d'un an à la gauche
sectaire et économiques qui je croisais
l'unanimité sur le rapport de jean louis
borloo a présenté par jean-louis borloo
pixels
qu'en est il de ce rapport sur la
question des villes et des banlieues une
chute de ventes sur la question de
l'avenir
cela dit montant minimum 25 ans pour une
réconciliation nationale
c'est une chose pour l'urbain et le
léger banlieue foncier des territoires
de au droit au pari d'un rapport qui a
été dit je j'ai fait ce choix allusion
maintenant parce qu'il vit pas troquer
l'aperçu de l'institut du développement
durable et des relations internationales
une heure à gosn sic en 2050 pour une
agriculture vue
fonctionnel pour une alimentation saine
et une redynamisation des territoires
ruraux tout en créant de l'emploi
merci merci merci joël ça c'est un petit
frein on va finir par deux collègues
jean marie jeune scène et ensuite henri
cabanel madame la présidente
mon cher françois puisque nous on sait
déjà rencontrées en loir-et-cher avec
jacqueline sa collègue aulas et la
collusion assez longtemps la mission que
vous a confiée le président de
république consiste à penser la france
dans les 20 à 50 ans qui viennent
oui je suis un peu trop dans le contexte
je vieillis sanitaires économiques s'il
joue à l'inter et économique que nous
vivons difficile de décoller des
inquiétudes du présent pourtant il est
tout à fait essentiel de sortir de
l'immédiat et de l'actualité brute afin
de bâtir la france de demain comme le
dit l'adage
l'avenir ne se prévoit pas il se prépare
parmi les premières leçons que nous
pouvons tirer de cette pandémie qui dure
l'une d'elles concerne la gestion
politique de la crise et l' équilibre
entre l'état et les territoires français
prise en tenailles entre entre un
discours scientifique hétérogènes une
très forte pression médiatique et
l'omniprésence des réseaux sociaux dans
le débat public la parole de l'état sont
très affaiblies face à cela nos élus
nous élus locaux ont montré leur
capacité à réagir à répondre à l'urgence
à être cotée des plus fragiles à sortir
de la rigidité administrative pour être
en phase avec les besoins du terrain
l'heure est enfin venue de faire
confiance au territoire français et de
leur donner pleinement les moyens d'agir
les français ne veulent pas davantage
d'états mais mieux d'état l'exemple des
arrêtés municipaux ce prix par de
nombreux maires pour sauver leurs
connaissances de pointe
limiter le commerce de proximité doit
faire réfléchir jusqu'au sommet de notre
natation
cet exemple est très révélateur d'une
situation de tension et
d'incompréhension forte d'élus locaux et
d'une partie de la population vis-à-vis
les décisions de l'état préparer
l'avenir de la france commence par
réaliser vraiment la décentralisation et
par rééquilibrer les rapports entre les
différentes strates de l'état nous ne
ferons à nouveau nation que dans un pays
où l'égalité des territoires est assuré
et où l'état est perçu comme
facilitateur facilitateur des choix
locaux je vous remercie
merci jean marie henri cabanel pour
finir cette deuxième série de questions
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
haut commissaire vous venez de dire que
l'exigence de la vie à moyen et long
terme passe par un travail de
prospective qui est indispensable et
notamment sous la vision de la
souveraineté volet de nous expliquer que
les élus n'étaient pas toujours
adéquation avec cette méthode parce que
quel que soit les exécutifs entouré de
technocrates ou souvent éloignés du
terrain il jaune du mal à s'approprier
donc les avis des experts les avis aussi
à travers les travaux nombreux fournis
par la scène nationale le sénat où ses
oeufs
car à mon avis ils sont trop focalisé
sur le tas de leur mandat
pensez-vous donc qu'il faudra pour
pallier à cela arrivait à avoir des
formations me pousser pour les élus
pensez vous que aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de démocratie participative
pensez vous qu'il faille que les élus
s'approprie aussi c'était démocratie
participative avec les outils qui
existent et avez vous d'autres idées sur
de nouveaux outils de démocratie
participative
voilà merci beaucoup en rimes sur le
haut-commissaire vous avez été interrogé
sur beaucoup de thématiques peut-être
voilà une réponse globale
donc je vais répondre d'abord à monsieur
chaize qui me prend par les sentiments
même s'il sait pas exactement les lacs
massif
oui mais c'est ça je chercher là bas
quand vous dites que non en réalité je
me trompe c'est pas ça qui m'a posé des
questions en premier de cette nouvelle
centrale missionné son diplôme
voilà je savais bien que je ne me trompe
pas de regard monsieur du plomb mais
donnons oui monsieur du plomb vous
prenez par les sentiments parce que vous
dit deux choses qui ont fait toute ma
vie politique
la première c'est que on ne peut pas
perpétuellement dresser une partie du
pays contre l'autre et si vous regardez
les élections américaines aujourd'hui
vous avez sous les yeux le résultat de
cette politique est soit dit avec un
clin d'oeil sans malignité aucune
s'il m'est arrivé de me poser certains
présidents de la république c'est parce
que sur ce point je trouvais que le les
choix stratégiques qui étaient les leurs
de d'alimenter les affrontements
entre une partie du pays et l'autre
était dangereux et j'ai toujours pensé
ça et c'est pourquoi je me suis toujours
opposée à la bipolarisation
mais la bipolarisation n'est qu'un
aspect marginal vous avez parfaitement
raison de dire catégories sociales quant
aux autres catégories sociales et vous
dit ben il faut rendre du sens à tout ça
et c'est le politique qui peut rendre du
sens alors ça m'a fait sourire parce que
j'ai écrit un livre sur ce sujet il ya
25 ans et qui s'appelait et sur le sujet
de la laïcité parce que c'est la même
question qui s'appelait le droit au sens
parce que je pense que le citoyen il a
un droit que les responsables publics
devraient prendre en compte et assumer
c'est donner du sens à notre action
collective à notre vie collective et au
fond ça rejoint tout à fait la dernière
question que monsieur cabanel m'a posé
c'est essais sous jacent dans d'autres
alors monsieur cabanel ces deux
affirmations mais c'est un set en écho
un fait des affirmations le premier les
élus sont trop souvent deviennent trop
souvent coupés des réalités c'est les
technocrates qui c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue là
l'interdiction du cumul entre un mandat
exécutif s'il avait beaucoup davantage
l'opinion le souhaitez et j'ai moi même
participé à cette réflexion il demain
qu'on a là une question de
l'enracinement et de la différence et
oui bah je vais je vais vous laisser le
faire après en tout cas je reconnais
qu'il ya une question de même qu'il y à
une question dans la distance entre la
haute fonction publique et la décision
politique et le terrain et je pense que
tant le président de la république a
proposé la une réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui n'a pas été suivie
d'effet c'est ça qu'il avait en tête
qu'il existe ou que se crée des chemins
différents de de respiration de ou de
perse pire à sion entre le terrain et la
décision au sommet administratives et
politiques
c'est vrai qu'on en est très loin c'est
vrai que la conception que
l'histoire longue de la france y compris
monarchique et la troisième république
et la vème république ont porté au
travers de une haute fonction publique
formés pour cela a eu des effets de long
terme qui sont d effet de distanciation
de séparation et je dis souvent c'est
milieu de décision ne parle plus la
langue que les gens comprennent mois moi
je n'oublierai jamais c'est pas hier
c'est à la fin il y avait des élections
et j'étais en campagne j'avais ce une
part de rôle national bien entendu
j'avais été au gouvernement et dans un
chef lieu de canton
un soir comme ça il ya une jeune femme
qui s'est levé et qui a dit écoutez
il faut que vous m'écoutez parce que
j'ai jamais pris la parole en public
c'est la première fois de ma vie je
voudrais vous dire quelque chose alors
on l'a écouté
je trouvais que c'était très émouvant et
très très intéressant elle dit voilà
quelque chose à vous dire moi le
mercredi après midi comme j'ai les
enfants à la maison
je repasse et j'allume la télé pour les
questions gouvernement et il faut que je
vous dise quelque chose
d'abord vous vous tenez mal si mes
enfants se tenait alors là tout a semblé
confondues 1
si mes enfants se tenait comme ça à
l'école je serais morte de honte il me
semble me souvenir d'exemple pas si
vieux que ça et puis deuxièmement je ne
comprends rien à ce que vous dites
parce que le langage qui est devenu le
nôtre et je dis notre sens le plus large
possible
administrateur fonctionnaires
et hautes fonctions politiques qu'elle
nous appartenons tous d'une manière ou
d'une autre
ce langage a pris par vocabulaire des
tournures une sémantique l'utilisation
de statistiques perdre et c'est plus le
langage que les gens parlent et quand
quelqu'un ne parle pas ce langage
toute allusion est exclu il est mal vu
il est mal vu et il ya là quelque chose
qui en est fait pour moi est une est une
question de rupture alors est-ce qu'il
faut une formation ce qu'il faut plus de
démocratie participative
oui peut-être plus de démocratie tout
court une nouvelle organisation y
compris du fonctionnement des assemblées
y compris des rapports entre les
assemblées parlementaires et l'exécutif
bon alors je suis constamment
minoritaire sur cette question y compris
parmi mes propres amis mais j'assumerai
ce set
cette question là en tout cas je pense
que c'est très important
monsieur guay pardon je saute pardon
madame artigalas je suis d'accord avec
vous sur un point c'est que le numérique
ne peut pas être le seul mode de contact
entre les dessine entre les
administrations et des citoyens
moi je suis exaspéré quand je dois
téléphoné à fournisseur d'électricité en
fournisseur d'eau fournisseurs de
téléphones c'est impossible pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas totalement rodé
à ces outils est assez langage de le
faire je pense toujours est ce que
serait la situation de ma mère si elle
était encore là essayant de rejoindre le
les plateformes téléphoniques
c'est impossible on vous demande votre
numéro d'usagé il est ou sur la sueur
sur la feuille dans un coin a écrit en
tout petit vous n'avez pas les lunettes
pour le faire et comme vous ne maîtrisez
pas ses codes
vous n'osez même plus appeler et c'est
vrai aussi pour les administrations et
c'est pourquoi deux alors on a envisagé
beaucoup de formules maison du service
public en tout cas il faut qu'il y ait
un truchement humain autant je crois aux
capacités de progrès du numérique autant
je pense qu'il faut garder du truchement
humains et cette sorte de en même temps
et pour moi quelque chose de très de
très important
monsieur chaize qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire contre les grandes plateformes
mondialisé et sur la question fiscale
eh bien c'est ce qu'on est en train
d'essayer de faire avec l'union
européenne
moi je pense que ça va s'imposer parce
qu' une des questions c'est que la base
de la matière fiscale dans cette crise
disparaît c'est vrai pour les
cotisations qui soutiennent la sécurité
sociale mais c'est vrai aussi pour pour
l'état et les finances publiques alors
vous dites le télétravail
il ya une limite au télétravail ce que
le dîner de travail au mieux ces faits
pour le tertiaire mais c'est pas fait
pour les usines c'est pas fait pour les
ateliers
c'est pas et là on a au contraire
l'obligation de continuer à avoir du
travail en présence physique et donc est
donc bon alors sur la 5g on en parlera
mais je lirai votre rapport sur
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique parce que si j'ai bien compris
c'est vous qui l'avez produit donc bon
monsieur guay d'abord merci de ce que
vous avez dit je suis d'accord avec vous
mais vous n'avez pas lu ce que j'ai
écrit comme me semble-t-il
on aurait dû se mettre d'accord pour que
vous ne lisiez dieu qu'en termes galants
ces choses là sont dites
bon pas ce que vous dites y'a pas de
rupture il ya une rupture absolument
essentiel est de ce point de vue là nous
allons nous trouver d'accord on a vécu
30 ans pendant lesquels on a pensé que
l'action publique ne devait pas diriger
les choses on a pensé que c'était les
décisions individuelles non non enfin
bon vous avez aussi été au gouvernement
non un peu voilà non non non non
dangereux de jeu je fais pas de
polémiques
polémique oui
par exemple moi pas mais et vous non
plus donc c'est bien ça fait 2 se fait
pas une majorité mais grosso modo le la
doctrine générale pour ne pas dire
l'idéologie général c'était que les
décisions prises par des parts d des
entreprises chacune pour leur compte
la somme de ces intérêts individuels
faisait l'intérêt général c'est ça qu'on
a pensé et des gens aussi différents que
si je prends les quatre derniers
présidents de
de la république jusqu'à jusqu'à cette
période ils ont tous pensé ça ils ont
pensé que ce travail de planification de
prospective
c'était un travail qui en réalité
n'avait pas de légitimité à diriger les
grandes décisions alors je pense en
effet que pour ce qui est de l'intérêt
de l'entreprise la décision individuelle
de l'entreprise est meilleur qu une
décision qui tombe du sommet je pense ça
simplement je pense c'est écrit en
toutes lettres dans la note que vous
avez si bien lui la somme des intérêts
particuliers ne fait pas l'intérêt
général et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous sommes nous nous trouvons
devant des ruptures d' équilibre les
grands secteurs où nous avons accepté de
dire d'où nous avons accepté de
disparaître simplement parce que c'était
plus intéressant pour alors en effet il
y avait là une idéologie et ma présence
ici signifie un signe que nous pensons
où nous pouvons commencer à penser le
contraire et retrouver un sens de
l'intérêt général prospectifs par
rapport aux abandons qu entraîne
inéluctablement le fait de décisions
d'intérêt personnel même s'il s'agit de
personnes morales individuel même s'il
s'agit d'entreprises et si on pose la
question comme ça alors on retrouve une
des inspirations qui a été celle de
l'après guerre et que moi je considère
comme toujours
nécessaire aujourd'hui et donc de ce
point de vue là oui il nous sommes dans
cette audition ainsi de rupture et le
nombre de ceux qui croyaient que c'était
pas possible et qui ont fait les gorges
chaudes de ce truc de la renaissance de
ce truc complètement dépassés archaïque
régressif
je tiens les coupures de presse à
disposition oui beaucoup de gens
pensaient que ce temps était révolu et
moi je pense que ce temps est désormais
nécessaire
autrement dit je pense qu'on n'est pas
la conclusion de quelque chose mais au
début de quelque chose c'est comme ça
que je le que je le ressens quand à
cette affaire de sault local je vais je
vais voir d'abord ça m'énerve que l'on
utilise des terminologies britannique
pour tout je trouve que je trouve que
cela
donc je suis d'accord je vais je vais
regarder ça si vous voulez mon bon
monsieur l'abbé monsieur là mais vous si
vous prenez par les sentiments parce que
mon ami jean louis borloo en effet fait
rapport intéressant et je ne connais pas
le deuxième rapport sur le
agriculture
et et nouveau développement de
l'agriculture
je pense cependant que il y a là une
voie que nous ne pouvons même pas
imaginer d'ignorer parce que si l'on
considère que les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sont la question
principale
en tout cas la question climatique
principal la question principale dans le
climat
alors nous sommes bien obligés de
trouver des substituts et il n'y a pas
de doute que les biocarburants par
exemple ou l'insertion d'une partie de
biocarburants je pense par exemple aux
carburants d'aviation
quels autres moyens avons-nous de quels
autres moyens disposons-nous que de
travailler sur ce sujet de
l'introduction d'une partie de
biocarburants pour que au total les
émissions des des due aux voyages
aériens baissent on n'a pas d'autres
moyens et donc je vous assure à l'avance
de ma détermination à aller dans ce sens
là et donc mais l'énergie faut aussi
avoir le courage de poser par exemple
j'ai déjà dit mais je répète ce que je
crois profondément
si l'on considère que les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur la question
principale alors s'agissant
d'électricité on peut pas continuer avec
l'idée qu'on peut faire ça et fermé des
tranches de centrales nucléaires tout le
temps même temps pour moi c'est c'est
absolument contradictoires le fait que
nous en ayons fermé récemment à fait que
on a été obligé de faire marcher des
centrales à charbon et quant à
l'allemagne
c'est un contre exemple c'est absolument
le contraire parce que que font-ils ils
ont fermé leurs propres centrales mais
ils achètent du courant électrique dans
les pays de l'est avec des centrales à
charbon qui sont qu'ils émettent
trente fois plus de gaz à effet de serre
que le nucléaire est donc si on peut
mettre un peu de cohérence dans cette
réflexion là alors ça ne veut pas dire
que korn qu'on ne prend pas les autres
formes par exemple moi je crois beaucoup
au photovoltaïque et à l'évolution du
photovoltaïque
je suis un peu plus embêté devant
l'éolien parce que il ya une forme de de
rejet et je viens de voir qu en baie de
saint brieuc
il y avait aussi ce genre de
mobilisation mais le photovoltaïque
en tout cas ça c'est de l'énergie
gratuite est sûr et on a de ce point de
vue là me semble-t-il des perspectives
de progression majeure
par exemple on travaille apo / du
photovoltaïque code appelle organique
vous savez que le photovoltaïques au
silicium
il a un bilan carbone discuter en tout
cas le pour équilibrer il faut sept ans
et demi de fonctionnement avant de re
fournir l'énergie qu'il a fallu pour
pour fabriquer les cellules au silicium
et pour faire fondre le silicium
on travaille sur le photovoltaïque
organique dans le bilan carbone n'est
pas de sept ans et demi mais de sept
jours et demi alors c'est encore
expérimental ça n'a pas lé la
productivité d'une cellules
photovoltaïques au silicium et encore de
1 à 3 mais c'est ça existe et donc ça
n'a pas les effets négatifs sur le bilan
carbone
et puis permettez-moi de vous rappeler
ce que vous savez certainement mais que
vous ne manquerez pas de répéter que le
seul la seule lit de transport en commun
à hydrogène du monde elle a été mise en
place à pau et je vous invite monsieur
l'abbé venir la visiter
quand je dis monsieur la blessure voilà
et donc
venez ça me fera plaisir un bon jean
marie jeanne 110 la parole de l'état a
été très affaiblie la parole publique
était très affaibli celle de l'état est
la nôtre le on est dans un monde où
toute prescription pour autrui est mise
en cause
c'est vrai pour les politiques c'est
vrai pour les médecins les français s'il
ya une des révolutions que cette crise a
entraîné dans l'esprit des français
c'est qu'ils ont découvert que les
médecins n'étaient pas d'accord entre
eux et non seulement pas d'accord entre
eux mais jusqu'à des affrontements
le passionnel sans mesure et donc la
prescription pour autrui est aujourd'hui
mise en cause et les politiques ce n'est
pas autre chose que les gens qui tentent
de prescrire pour autrui
on aimerait qu'ils prescrivent davantage
pour eux mêmes que pour autrui mais
voilà j'ai fini puisque j'ai répondu
henri cabanel aussi les questions
précises que vous m'avez posé il reste
une dernière série voilà on va commencer
par anne catherine loisier ensuite
pierlot
merci à mme la présidente monsieur
ministre donc rapidement d'abord je veux
vous remercier parce que n'auraient pu
avoir quelques craintes
la construction de ce nouveau
commissariat ce qu'on nous on empile
encore une technostructure
supplémentaire donc à vous entendre on
comprend qu'on est dans une structure je
veux bien mais que nos jeunes
voilà donc dans une structure de
d'anticipation de recul pour finalement
pour pour aller plus loin moi je
voudrais savoir comment vous allez
travailler avec les ministères puisqu'on
voit bien que votre champ est totalement
interministériel et que dans les propos
ou ne tenait bien sombre de propositions
qui vous font pas en cohérence avec ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui donc il faudrait
pas que cette structure devienne pour
autant quelque part uniquement un espèce
de think tank
que derrière il n'y a pas une réelle
emprise sur les choix
en tout cas je pense que c'est pas votre
ambition pour rebondir aussi sur les
interventions de mes collègues et moi je
voulais aussi souligné le fait que
depuis ces dix derniers mois on a fait
quand même un grand recul tout à l'heure
mes collègues parlaient des problèmes
d'accès au logement d'explosion de la
pauvreté et nous sommes je le crains
malheureusement qu'au début on a
beaucoup parlé d'isolement numérique
je voudrais juste aussi vous témoigner
pour en avoir à la maison la situation
effectivement des jeunes aujourd'hui et
des jeunes étudiants qui n'ont pas accès
au numérique qui ne sont pas dans des
territoires bien desservi je rappelle
que plus de 50% aujourd'hui des locaux
ne sont pas desservis par la fibre donc
il ya beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui
étudiants qu'on invite à travailler en
distance yale mais qui n'ont pas d'accès
à un numérique qui leur permettent de le
faire sur le pouvoir de la finance et
les sujets de la dette
moi je m'interroge quand même monsieur
ministre savoir si ceux qui tirent en
fait les ficelles ont ils vraiment envie
de sortir de cette opacité
je pense qu'on a tous un peu la réponse
donc donc voilà comment faire et je
repensais à l' einstein qui disait qu'on
on ne résout pas un problème est que
ceux qui l'ont créé donc une fois qu'on
a dit ça on voit les noms cités du champ
je voulais aussi vous interroger sur la
politique énergétique alors vous venez
d'en parler vous n'en aviez pas parler
dans votre intervention préliminaire
tout ce qu'on est en train de dire en
fait est totalement tributaire de notre
capacité de notre souveraineté
énergétique dans un contexte où les
ressources fossiles diminue et où les
coûts explosent tout ce que vous évoquez
le photovoltaïque tout ça avec des coûts
qui sont exorbitants donc il ya un mon
sens un vrai sujet de souveraineté de
disponibilité énergétique auquel vous ne
pouvez pas enfin échapper à mon avis
vous y avez largement amplifié pu enfin
une dernière question quels sont au
final selon vous les atouts différentiel
de la france à long terme et les leviers
sur lequel nous devons agir
merci
merci une catherine pierlot ensuite
daniels a dit oui monsieur le haut
commissaire toute politique au plan à un
volet aménagement du territoire
depuis le général de gaulle dans des
années 60 il n'y a pas eu
et là il ya de véritables exemples de
politiques d'aménagement du territoire
porté par le général de gaulle depuis
une trentaine d'années tout est au
bénéfice des métropoles des grands
centres urbains aux dépens financier
total de 80 % du territoire où
malheureusement vie seulement 20% de la
population et donc ses 20% sont
faiblement représentées dans les
décisions politiques
aujourd'hui on reparle des territoires
ruraux en parlant d'une
réindustrialisation de création
d'emplois 1
il faut une volonté politique 2 il faut
des moyens financiers qui existait il y
avait le feader autrefois qui étaient
réservés aux territoires ruraux et puis
maintenant il est réservé aux
territoires urbains il y avait des zones
de revitalisation rurale qui permettait
quelques avantages fiscaux de
contributions sociales
tout ceci a quasiment disparu
et pourtant c'est possible j'ai été
président d'une communauté de communes
en vingt ans on a augmenté l'emploi
salarié on a augmenté de 50%
l'emploi salarié urssaf sur le
territoire avec une politique
volontariste avec les moyens qu'on nous
offrait aujourd'hui on n'a plus ses
moyens et donc fatalement les
territoires le haut n'ont plus aucune
chance
eh ben je voulais savoir si vous
prévoyez dans votre projet de plan un
volet aménagement du territoire qui me
semble indispensable
merci
hier daniel seulement ensuite servi
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
haut commissaire tout d'abord merci
c'est vraiment très intéressant d'avoir
un peu de prospective dans un monde où
on est tout le temps dans le court
termisme et où on a trop souvent opposé
la fin du monde
à la fin du mois bien entendu les deux
vont de pair et donc il nous faut
réfléchir à tout ça et j'ai trouvé votre
note très intéressantes parmi les
rapports qui dorment
il y en a aussi une pile très importante
ce sont des rapports du giec mais je
sais que vous partagez ces constats je
voudrais simplement vous interroger sur
sur le numérique patrick chaize l'a déjà
fait est ce que le numérique est
vraiment la grande solution
ou est ce qu'elle ne fait pas un peu
partie également du problème
effectivement le numérique est de plus
en plus présent vous parler de ce qui
fait société est ce que le numérique
permet de faire vraiment société et puis
quelle est notre indépendance
vous savez que le numérique aujourd'hui
fonctionne pour le construire il nous
faut les terres rares que nous ne
produisons plus il nous faut pas mal
d'énergie et on a parlé un petit peu
notre indépendance énergétique je ne
suis pas d'ailleurs en accord avec vos
constats mais ça c'est un petit peu
normal sur le nucléaire sur le solaire
et l'éolien
mais voilà notre indépendance
énergétique est fondamentale comment
allons-nous comment voyez-vous cela et
vous avez évolué très largement sur la
dette
est-ce que vous évoluerez aussi sur la
consommation faut-il encore pousser
notre monde a toujours plus de
consommation
je vous remercie merci à daniel serge
mérillou ensuite olivier rythm and merci
madame la présidente
merci monsieur bayrou
moi je m'interroge sur le principe même
de la planification et du plein en quoi
est ce compatible dans une économie
mondiale qui est ultra libéralisé et
comment allez vous vous y prendre pour
associer les grands acteurs économiques
mondiaux dans cette politique dans cette
planification je pense par exemple aux
gaffes en jeu j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
sont suffisamment puissants pour
s'affranchir de toute tutelle et
parallèlement sur qui ou quoi vous allez
vous appuyez au niveau de l'étang pour
mener une politique active en matière de
planification
moi je crois à l'importance de la
aujourd'hui peut-être plus qui hier pas
plus qu'hier mais j'y crois moins
aujourd'hui
vous dites il faut réfléchir à long
terme mais les décisions à court terme
l'impact l'avenir
aujourd'hui on discute haut niveau par
exemple de la politique industrielle et
je prends deux exemples sur la vente de
la participation de l'état dans un
fleuron industriel qui est les chantiers
navals de l'atlantique
est ce que cette décision de l'état
n'était pas en train d'opérer les
possibilités de garder un poids
important au niveau de l'industrie
navale et puis un autre exemple ce sont
la signature des traités mondiaux et qui
je pense d'être du s'étant par exemple
et en quoi ces engagements la permettent
ils de sauvegarder notre indépendance en
matière agricole
voilà merci serge olivier wittmann
ensuite leur en somme on est bien en vue
termina merci madame la présidente
monsieur le haut commissaire j'imagine
toute la difficulté de la période que
l'on vit actuellement de pouvoir poser
un plan de prospective sur des 15 20 25
30 ans à venir
d'autant plus que si on veut qu'un plan
soit plutôt judicieux et solide il faut
quand même qu'ils soient posées sur un
certain nombre de bases or les bases à
l'heure actuelle les jours que nous
vivons aujourd'hui sont complètement
modifié remise en question
par cette pandémie et le fait que nous
vivions aujourd'hui est que nos
concitoyens vivent aujourd'hui plutôt
dans une situation due au jour le jour
me pose la question sur la justification
d'un tel plan et la solidité qu'on peut
apporter aujourd'hui avec ce manque de
base sur la justification d'un tel plan
deuxième partie de ma question la
propose le 28 octobre dernier et est là
on est plus sûr au jour le jour sur
france inter vous exprimer votre
opposition art confinement généralisée
je vous cite mon sentiment à moi c'est
qu'on ne peut pas refermé le pays sur
lui-même
complètement vous indiquez aussi que
nous étions davantage préparés à ce qui
allait arriver en cas de seconde vague
si je partage pleinement votre premier
sentiment
les récents événements donnent
malheureusement tort à votre seconde
prédictions ce que je regrette
l'actualité témoigne de l'absence de
dialogue avec les élus locaux et de la
confusion et de l'impro vision
généralisée dans les diction des règles
qui encadrent ce second confinement et
notamment par rapport aux dommages
collatéraux économique
je veux prendre pour exemple quelques
petits exemples la situation des
grossistes de boisson qui sont exclues
de nombreux dispositifs d'état la
situation des auto écoles qui pour qu'il
est possible de faire passer le permis
mais pas de suivre les cours la
situation aujourd'hui est très
préoccupante des producteurs de sapins
de noël qui voient leurs commandes
s'annuler de jour en jour et qui sont
dans une situation de panique mais
peut-être serons-nous vraiment prêt pour
la troisième vague en prévision quels
enseignements tirez vous de cet état de
fait qui me rassure pas c'est olivier
leurent saumon et ensuite vers le signe
du satin nude je faisais un clin d'oeil
sur le sapin
[Rires]
compris laurent segond ici à droite oui
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
commissaire pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
intitulé votre texte et si l'aco vide
il avait appelé si la colite durée et
vous n'auriez pu l'intituler et même si
la copie ne durait pas oui parce que je
suis d'accord avec vous on traite la
question j'en parle dans mon
introduction tout à fait est que
effectivement très content de cette de
ce retour du plan puisque finances en
rappel effectué en 1965 avec olivier
guichard qui avait mis en place gérer ce
premier sérieux vous avez cité
pour moi il ya trois éléments qui sont
très importants dans la crise que nous
connaissons et qui n'est qu' en
intérieur à la crise sanitaire connu
c'est la mondialisation de la
métropolisation et l'individualisation
mondialisation dont vous n'avez pas cité
le mot et qui est pourtant entraîner de
graves conséquences de dérégulation
aussi bien financières qu'on a connu en
2008 donc pu être corrigé depuis et à
l'idée de la désastreuse
désindustrialisation qui a provoqué
notamment les conséquences sociales
notamment en termes d'emplois sur le
territoire national deuxième point la
métropolisation là vous en avez parlé et
nous partageons complètement va je
partage complètement viré votre analyse
parce que ilham en ce sens
ça montre effectivement les limites et
les dangers de cette stratégie de
concentration à la fois de la richesse
mais qui a aussi concentré la pauvreté
dans le voit que les quartiers de la
ville et qui ont eu des conséquences
dans la crise du cog hill en termes
sanitaires jeu qu'on peut constater
notamment dans l'étude epic aux menées
par lens est ce que ce sont les
territoires les plus pauvres en milieu
très dense qui ont été les plus frappés
et notamment par les conséquences
parfois psychologique autant que
sanitaire heureusement la visualisation
qui était choisi auparavant mais qui
prend un certain type de population
comme la jeunesse est aujourd'hui cbi et
comme le disait sylvain tesson comment
empêcher un marronnier de bourgeonner
pour les cette expression était
remarquable parce qu'évidemment avoir
pouvoir contenir la jeunesse dans un
système où ils ne pourront plus sortir
se côtoyer vivre avec des suspects
perspectives d'emploi comme vous l'avez
dit qu'ils sont à ses cendres le facteur
déclenchant
comme vous l'avez dit aussi était
prévisible il était prévisible par le
livre blanc vous avez cités mais
également en cours
seize notamment par l'umr de montpellier
a traversé serge ces chercheurs
serge mourant et muriel fille et la mère
de mon colis qui a d'ailleurs beaucoup
travaillé dans le cadre je dirais de
cette pandémie et notamment dans les
tests antigénique pour lequel on peut
trouver un espoir en matière de
détection et de traçage on a cru
effectivement trop facilement
forts de nos compétences que toute la
technique allait résoudre tous les
problèmes et qu'on était je dirais on
serait épargné de ce risque de pandémie
tel n'a pas été le cas et je pense qu'on
aurait pu tirer profit davantage j'irai
des du monde animal et de la médecine
vétérinaire qui a traité un certain que
s'il était nerveux je m'inflige
intérimaire qui ait raid qui a traité
des épidémies d'une manière je dirais de
masse
là je dis pas naturellement qu'il faut
suivre tous les éléments mais que l'idée
que l'on ne cesse à de wayne s me
paraîtrait d'atterir à pouvoir faire
avancer les choses et d'essayer de
prévenir les risques d'épidémies
épidémiologique que l'on connaît et puis
quatrième le troisième le troisième
point qu'avec un point d'avancé dire
effectivement ça a été cité je vais pas
revenir de si mais sur la tâche ans
social val attachement au système social
de notre pays par mes questions sont de
trois ordres
la première c'est justement l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs que l'asie avec le contenu
davantage l'épidémie parce qu'ils ont
notamment fait des contrôles à la
frontière
donc est ce le retour à l'état nation
auxquelles sont attachées les françaises
et les français sens que je sois
considéré comme un gros mot mais il
véritablement comme également hubert
védrine en parle de vous n'avez pas
parlé j'étais un peu surpris du rôle de
l'europe ou de la france dans l'europe
ou de l'europe avec la france dans le
cadre justement de cette pro texte
stratégie de protection et
d'indépendance sanitaires et
industrielle et enfin je me permettrai
de cité
cité par hubert védrine laisse une
phrase de thomas gomart donc directoire
l'institut français des relations
internationales
et c'est un peu faire polémique mais
c'est l'occasion d'y répondre
est ce que vous ne pensez pas comme lui
que le mode de gestion des entreprises a
contaminé la sphère publique alors que
leurs finalités sont fondamentalement
différentes
on a tenu les notions de plans et de
planification pour obsolète au profit
des outils de gestion à horizon
trimestriels dans les business school
on n'a cessé d'encourager l'hyper
rotation des actifs la liquidité plutôt
que la solidité
moi ce que je disais non dans un certain
nombre de réunions on a pu préférer la
quantité des profits à la qualité des
produits
c'est dommage que fabien gay soit parti
et on va terminer par bernard bilicki et
en visio en face de nous faut qu'ils la
drôme au hasard bernard les dernières
questions qui vous sont adressés bon
merci d'abord de ce questionnaire très
complet donc moi aussi j'ai trouvé ça
très intéressant
un catherine loisier vous avez tout à
fait raison de dire que un certain
nombre d'étudiants se trouvent eux aussi
en confinement isolé des réseaux et il
n'ya qu'une réponse que j'aperçois ve
c'est que on doit mettre en place des
outils dans ces quartiers ou dans ces
communes qui soient des outils garantie
en
numérique en aliments réseau est ouvert
à tous à ceux qui font du télétravail et
aux étudiants qu'ils font on peut mettre
des espaces ouverts offert à ceux qui en
ont besoin
tant qu'on n'aura pas tous les
appartements où toutes les maisons
brand alimenter la réponse ne peut être
que de service public et il est vrai que
pour l'instant c'est pas c'est pas le
cas
je pense que les universités sont devant
un problème extrêmement difficile et les
étudiants devant un problème extrêmement
difficile je pense qu'on doit les y
aider
moi je me rends compte tout à fait de ce
que vous dites qu'en 50 % du territoire
n'a pas le haut débit c'est très
difficile de suivre de suivre les cours
ou d'organiser des travaux en distance
donc le rôle que jouait autrefois les
bibliothèques elles il peut être joué
par des espaces de travail à distance et
c'est là la responsabilité de la
puissance publique que de le faire
ensuite vous me dites vous me dites il
ya de l'opacité dans le monde de la
finance et est ce que tout le monde veut
résoudre cette opacité
d'abord je sais pas si c'est possible de
résoudre toujours l'opacité mais quand
vous si vous reprenez les chiffres que
j'ai donné à la louche finances officiel
un dollar sur trois finance plus plus
secrètes ou en tout cas moins
contrôlé deux dollars sur trois alors
vous vous mesurez vous mesurer la
puissance de tout ça mais justement
l'état ça sert à ça alors je jeudi en
même temps à monsieur saumon pour moi la
puissance publique je fais pas de
différence entre l'état national l'union
européenne et même les collectivités
locales la puissance publique locale
pour moi c'est un continuum dans lequel
l'état national a un rôle majeur
centrale parce que nous sommes une
nation qui se reconnaît dans un état qui
a d'ailleurs été formés par cet état ça
sera une discussion historique un peu un
peu longue et donc oui je pense que de
que de ce point de vue là l'état a un
rôle par exemple sur la question de la
souveraineté énergétique et on aurait dû
avoir un rôle en europe pour ne pas
laisser se faire ce que les nos amis
allemands ont fait c'est à dire ceux se
draper dans la vertu
entre guillemets ou dans la prétendue
vertus anti nucléaires pour aller ouvrir
des centrales à charbon en pologne
parce que c'est ça qui s'est fait et
donc c'est là où nous avons un dialogue
une discussion un débat que j'espère
intéressant enfin quels sont les atouts
différencier de la france au fond c'est
la question centrale ainsi si je n'avais
qu'une question à garder anne-catherine
ça serait celle là
quels sont les atouts différencier de la
france je pense que c'est un pays en
fait magnifiquement équipe et c'est un
pays avec une tradition de recherche est
une tradition industrielle très grande
c'est un pays qui a une histoire et
c'est un pays qui a une identité
encore une fois si vous regardez les
tensions incroyable de la démocratie
américaine aujourd'hui même nous sommes
un pays qui a la chance d'avoir une
histoire d'unités il nous revient de
savoir si on va abandonner cette
histoire d'unités aussi au contraire en
vain
on va la garder à part ça est ce qu'on a
fait tout ce qu'on pouvait faire ces
dernières décennies sur l'éducation par
exemple on est quelques-uns jean pierre
chevènement et moi par exemple avoir
suivi la même ligne et a regretté que
cette ligne n'est pas été continués
notamment sur les fondamentaux
je trouve qu'il ya des aspects de
culture générale qui manquent mais on
peut peut-être imaginer de l'éducation
populaire qui suppléait un peu voyez que
je je pousse l'idéalisme assez loin né
dans les nécessités que nous allons
vivre et le numérique joue un rôle
imaginez qu'on n'abandonne pas la
population parce qu'elle n'est pas formé
à la situation qui est la sienne
je pense par exemple à l'illettrisme jeu
ça fait des années que je travaille sur
cette question que je me suis engagé sur
cette question je pense qu'on va trouver
des outils qui vont permettre d'
apporter une remédiation en situation
d'illettrisme et donc le en tout cas le
niveau général de formation de la france
est un bon niveau général
le niveau général de la main d'oeuvre en
france est un bon niveau général
la question est quelle réponse on
apporte à ceux qui apercevant des temps
sans emploi apercevant des emplois ne
veulent pas aller vers ces emplois-là
pense à des choses aussi simples que le
bâtiment le la difficulté qu'ont les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment à trouver de
la main d'oeuvre alors que ya plein de
jeunes qui sont en situation difficile
c'est à se taper la tête contre les murs
alors est ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on
pouvait du point de vue de la défense de
l'image de ses métiers
l'apprentissage y participent parmi les
succès
des dernières années du gouvernement il
ya le bon formidable de l'apprentissage
a qui y ait une augmentation
considérable du nombre d'apprentis et de
leur image voilà en tout cas moi je
crois que nous avons des atouts
différentiel qui est il qu'ils sont
absolument remarquable bien lourd
l'aménagement du territoire et les
territoires ruraux
le mouvement des temps va ouvrir une
fenêtre d'action sur ce sujet ça que je
sens j'ai pas de preuve mais je crois ça
et je crois en particulier que on peut
harmoniser
on l'a déjà ville est question de dax et
lointain avec une présence humaine
garantie quelqu'un à qui parler et un
meilleur équipement numérique une
formation numérique
parce que moi je fais ça dans le dans le
plan anti solitude que nous avons mis en
place et dont je vous parlais il ya une
partie initiation au numérique pour tout
le monde y compris pour les plus
éloignés de de l'instrument
moi je crois ça possible mais ça veut
pas dire qu'on doive pas reprendre les
réflexions antérieur je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour le faire
et
alors monsieur salmon est ce que le
numérique est la solution où le problème
ben comme toujours on sait depuis esope
que la langue est le meilleur et le pire
le numérique ça peu isolé mais ça peut
réunir en même temps une partie de la
résolution de ces questions je crois
peut-être naïvement qu'elle est entre
les mains des gouvernants pourquoi les
gouvernants quel qu'il soit vous en êtes
tous des gouvernants pourquoi parce que
je pense que l'essentiel de la
responsabilité publique c'est pas
d'apporter des réponses toutes faites
c'est de donner aux gens des raisons de
vivre de vivre ensemble de se comprendre
et toutes les questions de laïcité sont
extrêmement lié à ça comment est ce
qu'on peut faire comprendre vous voyez
les débats internationaux y compris
comment est ce qu'on peut faire
comprendre que nous nous avons un
principe qui est un principe de
protection de liberté et de respect des
opinions liberté y compris de critiques
et en même temps de respect de
compréhension mutuelle et vous voyez que
toujours dans ces questions je prends
l'exemple de laïcité mais on pourrait
prendre des domaines qui me sont plus
proche encore dans ces questions là soit
les interlocuteurs n'entendent que
défense et promotion des libertés de
tout dire soit l'autre volet qui est
respecté et il faut faire comprendre que
précisément la démarche qui permet de
réunir les deux c'est ça notre principe
de vie et donc le numérique au fond ce
ça participe de ça et c'est un outil
tellement extraordinaire que qu'on peut
pas sans qu'on peut pas s'en priver
est ce que la consommation est le but de
tout non non et ça fait partie aussi de
nos principes de vie en commun nous
pensons que ça ne se se limite pas à ça
que que la réussite c'est pas la rolex
comme on va dire suffisamment souvent en
tout cas moi je le croise et je
continuerai à le croire et elle dira
même imprudemment alors serge mérillou
là bas
est ce que le mot de plan est bien
choisi je peux tout à fait entendre les
questions sur ce sujet pour collège
choisi parce que c'est un mot historique
parce que en le reprenant je relevais
comme on disait autrefois d'un titre de
noblesse
je relevais une tradition qui est une
tradition vital pour l'avenir dans notre
pays car comme vous je crois qu'on a
besoin de cette de cette vision de long
terme pour arrêter un cap qu'on suivra
et vous avez tout à fait raison de dire
que les décisions de court terme elles
sont liées aux décisions de long terme
je suis complètement d'accord sur ce
sujet
les chantiers navals déjà répondu un mot
sur le c'est à dieu sexe a été critiquée
dieu sait qu'on a eu des débats y
compris dans les rangs de delà de la
formation politique qui est la mienne
sur ce sujet qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qui a profité du ces temps c'est la
france dont le chiffre d'affaires à
l'exportation notamment dans le domaine
agricole avec
les pays concernés c'est à exploser les
grands bénéficiaires du cétacé nous ça a
été nous dans la période de convient de
vivre j'ai lu le rapport
j'ai peint philippe peut-être du canada
oui non mais c'est non je crois que ce
sont des chiffres établis bon et donc
normes et le mercosur sait pas on n'a
pas fait justement voilà donc on peut
avoir du discernement et je crois que
c'était assez juste
olivier rythm and vous disiez que
j'étais opposé au confinement
généralisée c'est vrai et d'ailleurs on
n'a pas eu le confinement généralisée
j'avais cité trois domaines dans
lesquels il me paraissait nécessaire de
garder au contraire les choses ouverte
en prenant les précautions nécessaires
premier domaine l'école si vous fermez
l'école vous fermez le pays deuxième
domaine les lieux de travail
je vais trouver catastrophique que le
travail s'interrompit dans un certain
nombre de secteurs et troisième domaine
les ehpad et c'est 3 domaines
sont demeurés en effet ouvert et donc de
ce point de vue là je n'ai je n'ai pas
changé de jeunes je n'ai pas changé de
ligne alors vous dites tout change oui
tout change
d'une certaine manière heureusement de
héraclite disait déjà ça il ya quelques
temps donc tout change tout bouge to
cool mais notre privilège à nous c'est
de pouvoir non pas prévoir ce qui va se
passer mais réduire les incertitudes
si je devais définir le une des missions
essentielles de ce commissariat au plan
nous sommes là face aux décideurs et aux
citoyens pour participer à la réduction
des incertitudes sur le numérique sur
l'énergie il ya des incertitudes qu'on
peut réduire pour avoir une action
cohérente une démarche cohérente
alors monsieur saumon j'ai un fils
vétérinaire donc je l'appuie tout à fait
et vétérinaire spécialiste de virologie
et notamment
2-2 d'épidémiologie dans le troupeau
donc c'est dire à quel point je me sens
en phase avec vous qu'est ce qui fait
que l'asie a mieux résisté à ça je vais
risquer une réponse peut-être n est pas
du tout admise mais il avait déjà des
masques et ne se touchaient pas depuis
des décennies et peut-être d'anciens au
japonais bien davantage est ce qu'il y a
un lien de cause à effet entre les
attitudes de vie qu'ils ont adoptés et
l'heure des rencontres très ancienne
avec des épidémies c'est possible c'est
possible et je suis assez prêt à parier
qu'après cette épidémie là on
s'embrassera - et on se salue ras de
plus loin que ne le faisait avant non
mais comme la vie privée ne me regarde
pas je vous je puis tout à fait admettre
que vous ayez des choix différents
mais mais mais il me semble que non je
pense que que notre manière de notre
proximité physique a joué un rôle dans
la propagation de l'épidémie
en tout cas je suis absolument certain
dans un département comme le mien les
vacances de l'été sur la côte basque et
l'extrême liberté que les gens à adopter
a joué un rôle dans leur démarrage de
l'épidémie je n'ai aucun doute de ce
point de vue là
et enfin bernard biya distance
oui je suis d'accord pour qu'on regarde
parmi les questions de souveraineté
pharmaceutique et la question des
vaccins de la grippe
en effet je je je promet en tout cas une
intervention rapide sur ce sur ce sujet
je vais je vais essayer de d'expliquer
pourquoi on en est là et peut-être de
suggérer des des éléments de réaction
voilà merci en tout cas c'était pour moi
très très précieux de vous rencontrer
merci monsieur le haut commissaire je
pense que la durée de la l'audition vous
montre l'intérêt que nous portons à
votre avis moi je retiens peut-être
quelques éléments la place de la
politique qui a été l'objet de plusieurs
plusieurs interventions et d'une prise
de voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition
de françois bayrou haut commissaire au
plan il était auditionné ce matin par
les sénateurs membres de la commission
des affaires économiques
à présent nous vous proposons de suivre
une autre audition celle de denis
massiglia président du comité national
olympique et sportif français
il était auditionné ce matin par les
sénateurs membres de la commission des
affaires culturelles je vous propose de
regarder leurs échanges et on se
retrouve après je souhaite quand même
faire une minute de retour sur la
situation post lima et quand je dis lima
c'est parce que lima était la ville
où le cio a décidé d'attribuer les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 à
paris nous avons rêvé pendant 6 ans 6
ans on a préparé cette candidature que
le fait d'obtenir l'organisation pouvait
changer la place du sport dans la
société française et que cette place
serait concrétisée à l'issue des jeux de
2024 je pense qu'on ne peut pas occulter
le fait que 2017 a été pour nous une
année 2010 8 plus exactement puisque
2017 c'était l'année de la décision que
2018 a été pour nous une année
compliquée au sens que alors qu'on
pouvait s'attendre à un élan ou une
impulsion et une place accrue en vue de
l'échéance de 2024 ça n'a pas du tout
été le cas et je rappelle que ça a
généré chez nous une pétition c'était
une grande première de faire une
pétition au niveau du moment sportif
pour expliquer qu'on ne pouvait pas
avoir une échéance comme celle qui nous
attendait et ne pas se donner les moyens
à la fois de la réussir et aussi de
pouvoir compter sur cette échéance pour
ce qu'elle allait déclencher en termes
de positionnement du sport dans la
société française après on est devant
aujourd'hui une crise qui met encore
plus en évidence les difficultés que je
viens d'expliquer donc effectivement
comment s'étonner
à partir du moment où on n'a pas donné
au sport et au mouvement sportif qu'il
anime la considération et les moyens
auquel il pouvait s'attendre que en
période de crise il ne sera pas reconnue
comme faisant partie des priorités de la
nation c'est quelque chose qui
est apparu totalement évident aux yeux
des acteurs du mouvement sportif et je
rappelle quand même que celui ci ça me
paraît important de le souligner est le
premier des mouvements associatifs
français
nous avons 90 fédération qui sont
affiliés au cnosf plus une quinzaine de
fédérations qui sont des membres
associés lesquels rassemblent au total
plus de 160 mille club et qui sont
animés par 2,5 à 3 millions de bénévoles
et rassemble au total pratiquement 10 7
millions de personnes licenciées si on
compte aussi toutes les personnes qui
sont passés un jour par un club et qui
savent ce que le club leur a apporté ça
fait quand même du monde et ça dure
depuis des années et des années et c'est
pas envie de faire un comparatif avec la
culture mais si on regarde tous les
discours des décideurs politiques le mot
culture apparaît pratiquement
systématiquement le monde fournier
jamais ou très peu souvent
et parmi les derniers discours que l'on
a entendu il a figuré dans le dernier
discours du premier ministre mais de
manière extrêmement fugitive donc c'est
vrai que nous avons un vrai problème de
considération de ce qu'est la chose
sportive par rapport aux élites qu'il
dirige la nation quelle que soit leur
origine
et c'est valable pour la droite pour la
gauche et pour
lorsqu'ali droite ni gauche donc
aujourd'hui avec la crise qui nous
touche
le problème est encore plus sensible et
on va distinguer si vous voulez deux
choses la sortie du premier confinement
où on a imaginé un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui permettait d'aider les
différents secteurs d'activité y compris
le sport et puis ce qui se passe
actuellement
donc pour ce qui est du premier sujet
c'est à dire on se met quelques semaines
voire quelques mois en arrière
une chose est certaine pour le ministère
de l'économie et des finances le sport
français n'existent qu'à partir de ce
qu'il peut rapporter de manière tangible
à l'état c'est à dire le sport
professionnel c'est incontestable que le
sport professionnel rapporte beaucoup
plus à l'état que ce qui lui coûte et
tout ce qui concerne les associations
employeurs sur 157 mille associations
qui sont aujourd'hui affilié à une
fédération et certaines seront faits
liés à plusieurs fédérations on peut on
peut dire que entre guillemets seulement
25 mille sont des associations
employeurs ce qui veut dire qu'il en
reste quand même 125000 qui sont animés
uniquement par des bénévoles
ces 125 mille associations échappe
totalement au radar de bercy parce que
elles n'apportent pas en monnaie
sonnante et trébuchante quelque chose
sur ce qui peut être lié à l'emploi et
parce que n'étant pas des associations
professionnelles
il est évident que elle ne rapporte pas
non plus sur ce sujet là donc une fois
qu'on a dit ça
nous on est bien obligé de dire que ces
125 mille associations et les autres y
participent évidemment elles sont quand
même essentiel pour tout ce qui est
création de lien social a pour une
éducation et je dirais à la fin
seulement apport de santé même si
dans les circonstances actuelles c'est
quelque chose de fondamental mais on
n'est pas les seuls à apporter quelque
chose en terme de santé par contre je
crois qu'on est les seuls à apporter
quelque chose en terme de lien social et
d'éducation parce que si vous n'avez pas
un éducateur pour s'occuper des jeunes
voir des adultes
vous n'avez pas ce que l'on appelle
vulgairement les valeurs du sport qui
peuvent être diffusées ici et là vers
ceux qui les pratiquent donc une fois
qu'on a dit ça on a plusieurs problèmes
aujourd'hui qui se pose avec l'arrêt je
veux dire l'arrêt de la nation puisque
c'est la nation qui est quasiment à
l'arrêt même si certain nombre
d'activités sont évidemment autorisé le
sport professionnel continu alors on va
dire quand même que c'est une très bonne
chose par rapport à l'arrêt qui avait
été ordonnée
il ya quelques mois et qui avait fait de
nous le seul pays où le sport
professionnel s'était arrêtée avec
quelques difficultés relatives aux
droits de télévision et puis aussi aux
contestations qui ont suivi par rapport
aux résultats
aujourd'hui le sport professionnel peut
continuer mais pour autant on va
distinguer ceux qui sont avec des droits
de télévision importants et ceux qui
n'ont pas ou peu de droits de télévision
parmi les sports que les droits de
télévision qui peuvent continuer il ya
que le football et de rugby actuellement
même le basket c'est quand même un sport
important n'a plus de contrat télévision
qui lui permettent d'avoir des droits et
heureusement key à la chaîne sport en
france qui a été créé par le comité
olympique est l'équipe qui relaie les
matchs de basket de jeep élite sport en
france aux armes aussi la promotion de
la pro b et de la ligue féminine de
basket et je parlerai un petit peu du
sport professionnel féminin aussi après
donc pour pour le sport crocs pour le
foot qui est dépendant essentiellement
des droits de télévision et avec le
sujet mediapro qui n'est pas un petit
sujet on se retrouve avec on va dire une
forme de continuité à laquelle tous les
clubs ont adhéré pour le rugby il ya un
problème essentiel qui est liée à la
perte de billetterie qui elle est un
élément primordial dans le budget des
clubs et de tout ce qui va avec parce
que en termes de partenariats et
d'organisation autour des matches il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont perdus
actuellement et même les indemnités qui
sont proposées ne suffiront jamais à
compenser la perte budgétaires liées à
l'organisation des matches je veux juste
dire que si les 107 millions prévus et
sanctuariser au niveau de bercy pour
dédommager en termes de perte de
billetterie sont reconnus comme pouvant
être distribuée par la commission
européenne pour autant la perte sèche de
billetterie de marketing de
roland-garros sur se situe à 100
millions
vous avez juste un échelonnement des
valeurs entre ce qui peut être donnée
est le coût réel de
l'interdiction de billetterie pour tous
et tous ces sports après il ya le sport
semi-professionnels ce que je
qualifierais alors je le qualifiais
comme ça parce que même si les
professionnels il est moins dépendant
des droits de télévision et là on a une
vraie problématique parce que
aujourd'hui sans billetterie ça on
recettes de télévision sans partenariat
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher de continuer
que si on arrête
mais si on arrête c'est une décision
fédérale et on ne peut pas prétendre aux
mêmes aides que si c'était une décision
entre guillemets d'obligations
gouvernementales donc on se retrouve
pour tous ces sports avec une équation
extrêmement difficile à résoudre qui
fait que les lits pro de ces sports et
les fédérations se réunissent tous les
jours pour dire ben on diffère ont fait
un arrêt de de quelques semaines donc
personne ne peut prendre aujourd'hui une
décision qui s'inscrivent dans la durée
compte tenu aussi du fait qu'on sait pas
quand on pourra reprendre une activité
normale
et puis jeté un éclairage sur le sport
pro féminin qui était déjà en difficulté
auparavant qui l'est encore plus
aujourd'hui salle sans un plan de
sauvetage du sport au féminin
il y aura plus de sport pro féminine
demain on peut pas demander aux clubs
éternellement de perdre de l'argent
et pourtant et pourtant ça devrait être
une priorité de pouvoir permettre aux
jeunes filles et lorsqu'elles
deviendront un peu plus tard aux jeunes
d'athlète féminine de pouvoir s'exprimer
dans un sport professionnel féminin
comme c'est le cas dans d'autres pays
il ya un vrai sujet a développé sur le
côté pour féminin nous
nous avons maintenant à voir quelle est
la problématique de tous ceux qui ne
sont ni professionnel ni semi
professionnels qui sont employeurs alors
pour ceux qui son employeur et il ya une
chance que à partir du moment où ils
cessent leur activité
les emplois sont pris en charge par le
dispositif gouvernemental et sait très
bien que le sport français puissent en
bénéficier au même titre que d'autres
secteurs d'activité reste la grande
majorité des clubs les 125 milles dont
je parlais tout à l'heure qui sont eux
animée uniquement par des bénévoles
alors la problématique aller simple
qu'elle est l'actif de ces clubs mais
leur actif c'est leur maman si les
membres ne sont plus là demain ils ont
plus d'actifs ils vont disparaître pas
tous mais beaucoup leur deuxième active
c'est les bénévoles qui les anime si les
bénévoles n'ont plus d'activité
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir l'esprit
suffisamment chevillée au corps pour
rester probablement que la plupart
resteront ceux qui sont les plus anciens
mais les plus anciens ont vocation aussi
à ce que leur action diminue au fur et à
mesure que l'âge avance donc on va se
retrouver avec une vraie problématique
de gestion de tous ces clubs amateurs
animée uniquement par des bénévoles qui
va se poser dès que
[Musique]
la pandémie sera finie alors si elle ne
dure que trois quatre semaines ça ira si
elle dure plus longtemps
je suis extrêmement préoccupé par
l'avenir de tout ce secteur amateur et
c'est ce qui a justifié la lettre
ouverte qu'on a faite au président de la
république
à un moment on le titre est illustratif
ces sports en détresse c'est pas autre
chose qu'une question de on est
désemparés désemparé par le peu de
considération dont on est l'objet alors
que on considère qu' on a un rôle quand
même important par rapport à la nation
et ce qui est encore plus difficile à
accepter c'est qu'on s'adresse à nous
quand il ya un problème
aujourd'hui on s'adresse à nous parce
que il faut lutter contre la
radicalisation et pourquoi pas puisque
c'est aussi dans les ambitions sociétal
du moment sportif que de pouvoir y
contribuer mais pour autant il faut
arrêter de promouvoir la pratique libre
de promouvoir la pratique associative
non fédérées parce que ceux qui
aujourd'hui la meilleure garantie contre
la radicalisation c'est d'avoir un club
qui est sous couvert d'une fédération
qui a un agrément
si vous n'avez pas un guide une certaine
organisation qui vous met des
contraintes tout est libre et
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on fasse une
enquête pour savoir quelles sont les
associations qui sont aidées pas
forcément par l'état mais par des
collectivités territoriales et qui ne
sont pas fédérer et qui sont des foyers
de radicalisation ça va être intéressant
quand même comme comme sujet on peut pas
s'en prendre aux clubs fédérés alors que
il ya autant de clubs non fédérées
aujourd'hui qui sont ici est la
bénéficiaire de dotation publique
il faudra à un moment qu'on soit bien
d'accord de faire le distinguo entre les
associations fédérées et les
associations qui ne le sont pas et je
parle pas de la pratique libre elle a
pris une certaine expansion ces
dernières années
là encore plus de possibilités du fait
des des cours en ligne pendant qu vis
des autres parce qu'à un moment lorsque
la vie normale reprendra
on reviendra aussi vers le côté
associatif parce que la pratique libre a
quand même quelques limites et notamment
pour les jeunes et je veux pas finir
sans parler des jeunes c'est pas parce
que je suis un ancien enseignant que je
dis ça mais prenez bien conscience de
quelque chose aujourd'hui les jeunes ont
une capacité physique qui est inférieure
à celle qu'avait leurs aînés non je vais
donc vous pour la plupart un jeune mais
entre 30 secondes et une minute de plus
qu'un jeune 10 à 50 ans pour faire 1 km
en courant tout ça c'est la faute à une
insuffisance d'activité physique voire
au fait qu' il faut surtout pas leur
dire qu'ils font de la compétition il
faut surtout pas leur dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aillent au bout de leurs limites
auront jeune quand il a dix ans 12 ans
13 heures il a envie d'aller jusqu'au
bout pour voir ce qu'il vaut il n'a pas
forcément envie d'être champion
olympique mais au moins pouvoir se
confronter aux autres pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de soi c'est extrêmement
formateur et en même temps ça l'est sur
le plan physique
sur le plan mental et c'est ça qui
manque aujourd'hui est le cri d'alarmé
qu'on donne tous et attention on se
prépare dans peut-être 20 30 40 ans une
crise sanitaire à côté de laquelle celle
du co vide ne sera pas grand chose la
crise sanitaire du à l'inactivité
physique à l'insuffisance de capacités
des jeunes d'aujourd'hui va se traduire
par davantage de maladies
cardiovasculaires et autres c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui
l'union européenne a signé à tirer le
signal d'alarmé dessus donc je le tire
aussi si on ne fait pas de la pratique
sportive des jeunes une priorité de la
nation on va droit à une catastrophe
nationale
merci de votre attention jeu disponible
pour vos questions et j'ai oublié de
présenter julie laver qui
et la directrice des relations
institutionnelles du cnosf qui peut
aussi répondre à mes côtés merci
monsieur le président je vais
transmettre sans plus tarder la parole à
jean jacques lozach pour entamer une
première série de questions journal le
jacques et le rapporteur des crédits
budgétaires du sport merci président
j'espère que vous tendez correctement
oui oui le président de business et d'il
y a bien résumé la situation à travers
cette lettre ouverte que le mouvement
sportif unanime avait très surprise dans
la république du 26 octobre dernier et
depuis je dois dire que les lis les
signaux d'alarmé pour ne pas dire les
cris de détresse se multiplient de jour
en jour aussi bien c'est concerne le
sport professionnel que le sport amateur
sans oublier d'ailleurs les loisirs
sportifs marchand je pense en
particulier à toutes ces salles de sport
ses 6500 salle de sport en france qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt et la
première question je voudrais poser à 1
denis masseglia c'est elle que là la
réponse budgétaire puisque nous sommes à
quelques jours du débat budgétaire
sénatoriales est-ce que la réponse
budgétaire qui nous est aujourd'hui
proposée par l'état et est suffisant
pour pour faire face justement à cette
situation très très très délicate
deuxièmement va je voulais revenir sur
les 107 millions d'euros qui était
aujourd'hui en débat à bruxelles mais
apparemment on n'a pas de réponse encore
précises comme vous l'avez indiqué tout
à l'heure donc je passe là dessus mais
en ce qui concerne puisque vous avez
débuté votre propos liminaire en faisant
référence à la préparation des jeux
olympiques
je voulais savoir si si à vos yeux ce
qu'on appelle l'héritage olympique et
notamment le volet de la étage olympique
concernant le développement du nombre de
pratiquants puisque l'objectif c'était
plus 3 millions de pratiquants est que
ces objectifs là ne doit pas être
aujourd'hui au regard de l'actualité
réévaluez prévalu et d'autre part je
voudrais vous demander une question un
peu
de direct mais à propos des échanges
entre l'état et le mouvement sportif le
10 sport com comment ça se passe
actuellement parce que on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il y ait au niveau de
matignon et en présence du premier
ministre qui était quand même l'ancien
dijonnais plomb c'est un délégué
interministériel aux jeux olympiques
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il y ait des
réunions des échanges directs et que
tout se passe au niveau des conseillers
du cabinet ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter quelques éléments de précision
là dessus
et puis enfin deux dernières questions
très fait très rapide
vous savez on est très remontés ici dans
notre commission culture au sénat sur ce
qui s'est passé dans le débat concernant
le sport entreprise au plfss elle
puisque il ya une sorte de retournement
de situation de la position
gouvernementale et dans le cadre de la
remise en cause de cet amendement de la
loi zap qui considéraient qu'il ne
considérait plus comme un avantage en
nature pour une entreprise la mise à
disposition d'équipements hung est tout
simplement toutes les aides qui
pouvaient être apportées pour développer
le sport d'entreprise ont des savoirs ce
qui abrogeait spx cette sorte de volte
face par rapport à ce que on appelait
l'amendement adidas et puis enfin une
dernière crainte une dernière inquiétude
puisque nous sommes au sénat et le sénat
est toujours très sensible à ce qui se
passe tous les territoires et notamment
lorsque les collectivités locales sont
se sont impliqués je pense au centre de
préparation aux jeux olympiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous sommes arrivés
à 1 619 sites qui ont été labellisés et
ça n'est pas fini
qu'est-ce qui dira d'autres arbitrages
qui sont aujourd'hui attendu ans quand
on regarde quand on décortique les
budget on s'aperçoit que pour justement
et aider notamment les investissements
qui sont prévus pour réactualiser en
quelque sorte et des équipements afin de
recevoir des équipes nationales ou
internationales
il n'y a que 20 millions d'euros 2
prévus sur deux ans 14 pour l'année
prochaine et 6 millions d'euros en 2022
est ce que cette crainte à vos yeux et
était justifiée voilà quelques quelques
questions préalables monsieur le
président
si ces présidents merci jean jacques
il a posé beaucoup de questions j'ai
commencé par un sujet mathématiques
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est logique
de prévoir 3 millions de plus de
pratiquants sur un homme qu'on ne sait
pas évaluer puisque c'est des
pratiquants qui ne sont pas licenciés
donc c'est une estimation et on estime
qui a peut-être 15 peut-être 20
peut-être 1 5 million de gens qui
pratiquent en dehors d'un club fédéré à
partir du moment où on ne sait pas
évaluer ce moment il me semble assez
illogique d'imaginer qu'il puisse
augmenter
c'est juste une question d'appréciation
mathématiques pour autant à partir du
moment où il y aura plus de pratique
sportive
on va dire que tous les secteurs
d'activités liés au sto en profiterez
que ce soit le club fédéré que ce soit
le secteur marchand que ce soit la
pratique individuelle donc je suis
évidemment favorable est éminemment
favorable à ce qu'il y ait une
incitation à la pratique sportive quelle
qu'elle soit et à un moment donné ça
sera à nous de montrer que pratiquée
dans un club est plus intéressant s'en
vient au problème du budget évoquée par
jean jacques s'est dit tout à l'heure
que la plupart des associations amateurs
n'étaient pas sous le radar de bercy
donc pour qu'elle le soit qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
d'abord leur demander à elle ce qu'elle
attendait quel est l'état de leur
situation dont nous avons lancé depuis
la semaine dernière une vaste enquête
auprès des clubs alors c'est parfois un
peu long pour que la déclinaison depuis
la fédération jusqu'au club se fasse en
particulier pour les fédérations un
effectif important on est ce matin avec
seize mille clubs qui ont répondu je
pense que
combien pas encore des clubs de foot de
tennis de ruby qui ont répondu ça va
forcément augmenter de manière assez
rapide et nous attendons une réponse
pour le 10 novembre de façon à pouvoir
indiqué dans un premier temps qu'elle
est la perte de membres
quelle est la perte de licenciés quelle
est la perte en recettes qui est
occasionnée et pas simplement par les
cotisations mais aussi par tous les
à-côtés du type billetterie du type
petit partenariat mécénat le club qui
organisait un loto une soirée pour
arrondir les fins de mois etc qui nous
permettra d'avoir une meilleure
estimation de ce qui peut être entre
guillemets le manque à gagner du
mouvement sportif associatif même si par
ailleurs on nous rétorque assez souvent
que oui mais comme il n'y a pas
d'activité n'y a pas de charge
c'est pas vrai ça il ya moins de charges
mais y'a pas à dire il n'y a pas de
charge et on peut on connaître
évidemment qui en a - dont ce que nous
souhaitons c'est que il y est d'abord
une indemnité que je qualifierais
d'urgence parce que effectivement les
clubs qui sont dans la difficulté
doivent être aidés pour pouvoir
continuer leur action et puis il ya tous
tout le dispositif lié au plan de
relance qui peut être ensuite mis mis en
place
je sais que le plan de relance est
quelque chose qui a été évoqué
par jean jacques lozach dans le cadre de
ce qu'on pouvait appeler le passeport
sport ou une allocation sportive de
rentrée je crois que si demain à la
reprise
à la relance il n'y avait pas ce
dispositif ce serait une faute grave
donc il faut que les uns et les autres
nous militions pour qu'il y ait une
incitation aux familles qui ne doit pas
être comptée comme dans le cadre du
budget sport c'est une aide aux familles
comme il ya une aide à la rentrée
scolaire combien une allocation de
rentrée scolaire comme il ya un
passeport culture même s'il n'a pas
donné les effets escomptés mais peuvent
tout garantir qu'un passeport sport lui
donnerait les effets escomptés
en tout cas il est attendu on a demandé
aussi dans l' enquête
quels étaient les préconisations que les
clubs souhaiteraient pour ce passeport
sport avec évidemment
les limites pour les jeunes pour des
conditions de ressources et autres qui
pourrait être fixé sur celui ci donc ça
c'est pour la relance pour le plan
d'urgence
il ya quelque chose qui est important
qui concerne le fait que ça puisse
passer par un dispositif qui a fait ses
preuves
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous se
sont posés la question de l'intérêt de
l' agence nationale du sport pour avoir
été un militant de la première heure
pour une gouvernance partagée
je peux dire aujourd'hui que
l'organisation de l'agent national du
sport elle fait l'unanimité et je dis
bien l'unanimité chez les fédérations
alors que ce n'était pas gagné au départ
et donc pourquoi le fait parce que les
fédérations se sont rendus compte d'un
certain nombre de conduites et dans la
gestion du cnrs le centre national de
développement du sport précédent où
parfois on aider de manière
spectaculaire des associations qui ne
faisait pas de licence et qui donc était
plus des professionnels de la subvention
que des professionnels de l'activité
il n'y a pas mieux qu'une fédération
pour connaître ces clubs que ce soit
directement ou que ce soit par
l'intermédiaire de ses structures
déconcentrées et donc aujourd'hui il
nous semble indispensable d'améliorer
considérablement la dotation qui passe
par les projets sportifs fédéraux parce
que c'est la meilleure manière d'être
sûr que l'aide au club va aller
vers les clubs qui auront le plus
d'actions à la matière donc quand le
premier ministre a indiqué qu'il pouvait
débloquer 122 millions dans le cadre du
plan de relance et nous sommes avant la
noce du deuxième confinement bon
évidemment qu'on va pas faire la fine
bouche et que on a approuvé avec
satisfaction la décision qui a été prise
pour autant et sans la comparer à
d'autres secteurs d'activité on aurait
peut-être pu prétendre à mieux
et pour autant je tiens à attirer votre
attention sur le fait que dans ces
centaines de millions qui se divise en
deux parties puissent y assez sur deux
ans il ya 50 millions pour les
équipements et on va dire pour la
rénovation thermique et autres des
équipements alors qu'il ya des
équipements nouveaux à construire
évidemment il ya 40 millions pour
l'emploi j'ai attiré l'attention des
deux ministres sur le fait que demander
à des associations de créer des emplois
dans une période où elles sont en
difficultés de fonctionnement
ça va être quand même très compliqué
leur priorité va être de garder les
emplois qu'elles le sont et puis ya
entre guillemets seulement 30 millions
pour le dispositif fédéral donc
et sur ces 30 millions il y en a neuf
qui vont à l'innovation technologique
on aurait pu aussi nous consulter pour
savoir où ils étaient les priorités mais
il reste donc à la fin 20 millions 21 de
dire 11 et 10 sur les deux ans qui
arrive pour l'aide aux clubs via les
fédérations l'aide supplémentaire au
club via les fédérations c'est évident
que c'est notoirement insuffisant et qui
va falloir tenir compte des résultats de
l' enquête que nous faisons pour que
l'on puisse espérer sauver les clubs qui
sont en difficulté et permettre à ceux
qui ne sont pas encore en difficulté de
ne pas l'être à la fin de la pandémie le
l'estimation que l'on peut faire
aujourd'hui je parle au conditionnel
parce que pour certaines fédérations
il n'y a pas de baisse de licence pour
la plupart il ya une baisse
significative il se pense que le chiffre
moyen auquel on va arriver va être
autour de 25% et si ça continue
certainement supérieure à 25% donc nous
avons une comparatif affaires au 31
octobre et on a prévu d'en faire un
autre au 31 décembre le comparatif
d'aujourd'hui même s'il n'est pas encore
suffisamment précis je pense qu'il le
sera dès les résultats de l' enquête à
partir du 10 novembre sur 25% de
licences en moins et de cotisations en
moins
je vous laisse faire le calcul nous
sommes avec à peu près 15 millions de
personnes licenciées si vous prenez donc
le 25 % ça fait 4 millions de personnes
vous multipliez par un chiffre moyen de
40 euros par licence a fait déjà 160
millions qui sont le manque à gagner du
dispositif fédéral
quant au club la cotisation est temps
moyen entre trois et cinq fois voire dix
fois le prix de la licence
vous avez comme manque à gagner
pratiquement le milliard d'euros qui
concerne l'activité mouvement sportif
donc c'est quand même pas des petits
chiffres je dis pas qu'il faut
indemniser à la hauteur de ce qui est
perdu il faut juste avoir conscience de
ce que ça peut représenter en termes de
financement voilà je finis sur l'aspect
budget sur
le côté sport entreprise oui le vote qui
a eu lieu au parlement nous a surpris
on va dire fâché on a fait un communiqué
de presse pour dire qu' on ne connaît
absolument pas la décision qui avait été
prise et si on considère que favoriser
le sport en entreprise relève de un
avantage en nature pour l'entreprise
autant dire que le sport ne compte
encore moins que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer dans les prévisions les plus
optimistes donc
j'ai vu hier qu' il y avait eu un accord
entre la proposition formulée par votre
collègue michel sa veine et les services
de bercy mais pu suivre l'audition de
denis masseglia président du comité
national olympique et sportif français
ils étaient auditionnés donc ce matin
par les sénateurs membres de la
commission des affaires culturelles
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup de l'avoir suivi je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver toute
l'actualité parlementaire sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une excellente journée
à tous
[Musique]